okay good morning everyone and can I
welcome you to uh development control
committee a of M District Council I just
need to run through some of the domestic
arrangements before we make a start uh
can I please ask you obviously when
you're out and about in the CH in the
chamber out in the Comm eras please do
try and do all you can to maintain
social distancing please ensure that you
wear a face covering at all times unless
you're sitting down or of course if
you're exempt from doing so and that
please continue to use hand sanitizers
and wipes that are provided can I please
ask everyone to make sure that when
you're not speaking your microphones are
turned off and please do not interrupt
other speakers or'll hold separate
conversations While others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave the
chamber can I ask everyone just to
double check your mobile phones on
silent or Switched Off please and also
could I just ask that you uh turn the
volume down on your PC uh to avoid the
um pinging throughout the meeting thank
you um we will be using an EV voting
system as always for this meeting on the
modern do go.app so if I can ask members
just to please make sure you are logged
in if you haven't already done so if I
can remind everyone present this meeting
is being broadcast live on the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you'll
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you're also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcasting Andor
training
purposes the council members of the
public and press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully
excluded uh if we hear the fire alarms
today can I ask you to please leave the
building immediately via the fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
at iown football ground please follow
the signs directing you to the fire exit
at each end of the floor please do not
enter the ground floor area the Atri and
the walkways if you're in the at the
time of the alarm please follow the
signs to the nearest fire exit use use
and please use the stairs rather than
lifts and do not re-enter the building
till we're told it is safe to do so okay
I think that's the technicalities just
just in case we've got anyone here
waiting for any items um item number 7c
which is DC
22927 land Northwest of Hill housee Lane
in need Market that application has been
withdrawn from the committee today so we
will not be heard
yes thank you um yeah I did given that
most of us have read 200 pages of papers
for that one I did um wonder if we could
have a little more explanation as to why
it was it been withdrawn and um and I
particularly wanted to say that I
welcomed the first time the report
including a section on sustainable
design and energy which is very welcome
so it's disappointed we're not actually
going to deal with it that that
application was due to come I'll let
John come in but at the briefing
yesterday it became clear that Alex
Scott was still really unwell and he's
the one with all the knowledge and the
information on it that was one of the
reasons John anything else to add know
but not really that's essentially it
unfortunately it would be unfair to the
applicant uh for me I'm already unfortun
doing a couple today uh to take that one
on as well and know everything that the
case office knows and it would probably
be a risk of bias that I'm not equipped
to uh answer any questions of members or
present it adequately um so we did take
the decision it's actually the first
time we've done that in the an illness
of of an officer has caused us to do
this um we do apologize but we just felt
it would be unfair uh if we didn't have
the officer so thank thank you that
that's a very helpful explanation and
and I do think that um the committee has
had problems um when a substitute
officer has been brought in at the last
minute so I I think if it's a complex
item like that we felt we should have
the case officer in the briefing
yesterday okay introductions we have
John pman G who we've just heard from
who's the area planning officer we have
Ian depre who's our legal advisor uh and
we have uh Claire uh Robert Mandy who
are either side who keep the meeting
running and flowing and uh they keep the
order behind the scenes so thank you to
them just as a point of interest is
Robert's last meeting today uh as he
leaves us I won't be here for the whole
day in case this runs off on so I just
want to formally just thank Robert for
the great work he's done for this
committee and the other committees
during his time at mids thank you
Robert okay so we'll move on uh just one
final thing I should say is Ward members
at mider District Council have the
opportunity to speak on an application
uh but may not vote and we have Ward
members sited at the front row who will
introduce for each relevant item okay so
we'll move on to the agenda uh apologies
for absence do we have any please me see
the wrong way
thank you um uh do we need to receive
any Declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by
members um I'm just going to just
declare that in application uh uh B uh
which is uh kits Meadow and stonum Asel
um I have used that architect practice
myself for some
work okay anything else no okay thank
you um any Declarations of lobbying of
members it's been it's been quiet un
yeah okay thank you uh any Declarations
of personal site visits yes councelor
Manel uh thank you as I mentioned at the
last meeting I made a personal site
visit to um Item B when it was came to
committee a few years ago and I
regularly um go past um the site for
item a but that's in my ward anyway but
I am pretty familiar with that site
thank you uh yes yeah I I also went on
on actually a committee site visit to co
Meadow some years
ago okay thank you for that uh we'll now
move on to confirmation of the minutes
of the meeting held on the 10th of
November 2021 which are in our paper
starting on page
seven um any points matters of accuracy
they run through to page 20 any points
of accuracy anyone wishes to raise I
happy that I signed that as a true
record of the meeting later on is that
agreed oh sorry we can't do that we have
to do it through the computer a proposal
for councelor pmore and second for
councelor eburn thank you and we need to
go to an electronic vote
sorry thank you chair members if you
select the plus sign in the top right
hand corner of your app that vote is now
in
progress
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for so that's carried L thank you
thank you very much I'll sign those uh
later on this
morning okay so we now move to um
notific do we have any notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme n CH okay so
we move on to the sched of planning
applications the first one before us is
na
2117 uh
sorry uh it's 2102 956 land of waren
Road West of uh Crest Meadow Way in
elmswell and now hand over to John pman
G who's going to take us through the
application thank you and good morning
so this land uh east of War Lane and
this is an outline Planning Commission
uh with access to be considered all
other matters are reserved it's for the
erection of
[Music]
44 so like a very big mosquito or
something oh so uh erection of 44
dwellings uh includes Bungalows
affordable housing open space and
Landscaping and Associated
infrastructure so this is the location
plan we'll start with with this um the
site is surrounded by existing uh
residential development almost all the
way around uh with the exception of the
South Boundary and part of the Southwest
boundary uh this we have is this is
Elwell this is the aerial photograph of
elmswell and the site essentially fits
in
there the site's an interesting shape um
it end in line with the Woodland uh
Woodland cors the South which this
doesn't work hang
on that
on ah there you go turn
on right so this the Woodland Corps just
to the South there and and the site
essentially lines up across there so not
that far up but along
there
the north side um is surrounded by
Gardens with the exception of a gap to
the uh East which is to the road just
there uh that's Crest Meadow Way uh to
the east uh where a pedestrian link uh
is proposed uh but this of course could
be a cycle link and to the West there is
a track that leads off here and goes
into uh Warren
Lane again that's proposed to be a
pedestrian uh Link at this
time to the South we have
um a curious change in the field here
and actually that's quite useful because
essentially across this point was the
previous scheme for 38 whereas this
scheme is looking to extend the land
across here uh to meet up with the end
of the the Woodland
there um we have War Lane to the west
and the access uh to waren Lane as the
previous scheme 38 will be uh around
here uh this uh scheme also includes uh
the re relevant improvements uh to
Warren Lane including passing spaces and
Junction
improvements the constraints plan um
essentially the site is outside the
settlement boundary there's no specific
uh constraints to highlight for the site
itself um so um yeah the allocation of
this site is for 38 houses uh which
covers the land and just detailed
before then we have a landscape plan
indicative and if we go into that sorry
back up one so that's the layout plan my
mistake indicative um a low density uh
indicative plan demonstrates a possible
layout of Housing and parking as well as
significant landscape and open space
buffer this sort of starts obviously
right at the top and works its way down
the side of the development and all the
way around
uh to the South and Western
edges then we have a landscape plan I'll
just go into that in a bit more
detail so the indicative plan says that
this area at the top could be Bungalows
and certainly this would be appropriate
given the surrounding existing houses um
but it's also a form that would create a
nice sense of place surrounding the
attenuation Basin um while in indicative
there's a lot of work that's gone into
ensuring that the surface water uh
matters are addressed and we have got
the details of the attenuation Basin uh
with the application indicatively that
they are shown to be um viable and uh
appropriate this is not the typical deep
Basin that we've been seeing in the past
um this is very much the shadow shallow
Basin approach that the suffi County's
guidance issued at the beginning of this
year now seeks to Sue and the sort of
set of deeper holes that we've had in
the last few years uh we're moving away
from
that to the South again the amount of
space for a low density development is
difficult to appreciate on a PowerPoint
I appreciate but essentially the space
means swes are a clear feature of the
layout alongside the open space
dwellings are set back from the road uh
by a little way garaging and parking is
cited to the sides of dwellings not
dominating the frontage of dwellings um
we have space for trees to mature uh
into so we do have some indications of
the indicative mix of properties with uh
the proposal but this is not fixed um
but we are looking at a range of
properties and you we got a space to
essentially achieve what mix we need to
achieve to meet housing need uh
affordable housing mix will be a matter
secured by this application and part of
the 106 agreement um for securing the
affordable
housing we have surface water
details and as I have said these have
been developed quite far in the outline
process and considered acceptable as a
workable viable surface water drainage
proposal most is open um but not all of
it is open but most of it
is and just to add to that we have the
drainage details just to point out the
top is essentially the reality the
bottom is
exaggerated uh so it's almost like a did
a diagram uh in order to show you the
measurements and the
details and we have AR cultural
information as
well essentially the important trees are
to the edges of the
site and looking at some
photographs we have the view from within
that top northern part of the site
looking through the Gap to Warren
Lane and we have the view at the bottom
end of the development on war Lane at
the
moment look here
across and we have few
and it is open to the south at the
moment
across and we also have sort of the
internal view of the northern section as
well and this top one if go back to the
white mouse is looking at the uh
essentially the fence line here in the
corner is the fence line
here looking wider a field these are
taken from the uh extensive uh landscape
impact assessment submitted as part of
the
application just to look at the various
views and how it may how a development
May inter interact with those
views and we can go this is actually
looking West um from the new development
that's being built uh just to the west
side of elmswell um if you look a little
more to the right you'll see the
construction site but essentially the
the coppus and Woodland hides a lot of
the development on one side and you will
see some of the development within that
inner northern part of the development
site surrounded by the existing
houses just to take a few some other
views of the site this is obviously from
Warren Lane looking across at where the
site will
be and looking
out to the surrounding
area I'm just going to quickly go
through these because hopefully they
Fair the views taken so this is looking
south from the site entrance
area and standing within the site
looking
southwards and then we're back to the
northern part again of the site
enclosed and looking at the back of the
gardens that surround
it
right so planning permission has been
approved again outlined for 38 houses
and the majority of the site is
allocated this proposal is for 44
instead and extends the area of land but
results in a less dense development um
despite the increase in
dwellings um as the indicative plan
indicates and demonstrates much of the
extended land is for landscape and
drainage uh works this also allows for
more spacious development meaning
parking can be better dealt with and the
Northern Area surrounding the housing
can be very low density even
Bungalows the improvements to Warren
Lane are secured
again the recommendation is for approval
given the shift in concern on climate
change and biodiversity indicated by the
nppf this application compared to the
previous application now has a number of
conditions that reflect the need to
address these matters and I will note
that these are concurrent current with
Reserve
matters in my report I have reflected
that some of the county requests for 106
agreement are not reasonable uh given
the allocation and the planning history
as well as the judgment on what is
needed to mitigate any burden of this
development a letter from the county has
been submitted in relation to this and
this is in your late papers uh don't
know if you've had a chance to see this
because it was uh late last night
um we have discussed these matters with
representative of the county team and
the chief planning officer and we have
decided to seek a review on the
educational matters
sort on this basis the actual
recommendation before members is
essentially unchanged because it already
seeks a 106 agreement on appropriate
terms to the satisfaction of the chief
planning officer as summarized in your
report as those and as those May deem to
be necessary by the chief planning
officer so essentially what we're saying
here is we may need to review the
educational arrangements and requests of
the county we have or we're asking for
uh authority to have that
negotiation and depending on the results
of that we may um seek to add some or
all of the monies require requested by
the county as part of the 106 agreement
but the authorization in your
recommendation
already says to give the chief planning
officer the ability to do that so I'm
not looking to change the recommendation
but I'm saying that there might be a bit
more to it in terms of what we do behind
the scenes before we go any F further
forward um the concerns of the parish
and objections are noted this is a
larger site than they may have expected
but the level of development is an
increase of only six units alongside
clear benefits of low density and as
described and on on this basis my
recommendation is one of approval as per
papers thank you thank you very much
happy to open it up to questions to
colleagues yep councilor Matson thank
you yeah my my first question is the
Bungalows um the the um the title
description of the development um says
Bungalows it doesn't say um nine
Bungalows um and um so I wanted to make
absolutely sure um that at this stage
outline stage we are securing nine
Bungalows um I don't think that says
that in the um in the conditions or
anything uh the answer is no we're not
securing Bungalows um there might be at
least one Bungalow because otherwise
it'd be in breach of the description but
we we have no defined number secured uh
the housing mix is not at this time uh
defined at the outline stage the height
of the buildings EG scale uh appearance
to the buildings layer to the buildings
are still going to be reserved matters
uh for for later stage so no we don't
have a specific uh securing of bungalows
in this
case uh
councelor eburn sorry I wrote down
mantel but I meant e I've done that
before I apologize through me counc
eburn thank you very much chair um thank
you John for the presentation um I've
got um quite a few questions actually
unfortunately but if I can just ask
three to to start with um you stated in
your presentation that the majority of
site the majority of the site is
allocated um by that I assume you mean
in the draft joint local plan and do I
therefore understand that the additional
part that's been asked for um has not
been allocated and can you confirm that
within the draft joint local plan any
revised settlement boundary would have
been around the allocated site and not
including the um New the the further
extension into the countryside that's um
my first
one um secondly you don't mention in
your report um the Quarry um which is
situated to the southeast of the site um
and
um which the parish council has has
mentioned and I understand there have
been complaints from residents um in
that area of where this application is
about noise nuisance and dust can you
show on a map please where that quarry
is um for the benefit of everybody and
also um can you confirm whether there's
expected to be an extension of that um
Quarry and finally if I may um there's
mention of a player area um which in
some parts of the report says secured
and some parts says not says proposed so
just can you confirm um what the um
status is of of the play
area thank you very
much there would me just to check on the
play area
um
in the
recommendation I have secured open space
and management of but not a play area so
if members wish a play area to be
secured that would have to go into that
part of the
recommendation uh so officially there is
no play area that I'm aware of secured
as part of this proposal but it might be
a matter of debate for members um could
we put the scen scen back up again if I
may ask on the PowerPoint thank
you CH chair if I may come back on page
30 under public realm it says it it
references the play area and says public
realm officers would like to see some um
play provision provided or a
contribution made and you've put officer
note this is secured so is it secured
that there's a contribution made or is
it secured that there's a play area
thank you no that's that's an error on
my part I have not continue that through
to the
recommendation
um bear with me one
moment okay I think on the layup plan
the play area indicative there was a
small area down here that was a small
play area but I'm I would have
to say no problem would securing that if
that's what members wish to do on site a
play area to be agreed and I would add
that to the
recommendation uh I apologize for my
mistake not continuing that through in
the report
um going back to the
Quarry I can't that one
does that
help so that's the querry
here um there's some measurements to say
roughly how it Associates with various
parts of
elmswell um they are rough measurements
I will say they're taken off a certain
scale and and just put in so please give
me the leeway of a few meters either way
um the only indication of an extension
that I'm aware of and I'm not I don't
work for the county so I don't know what
their ultimate plans are uh is that in
2017 there's a uh document that says
that this area here was being considered
for expansion but I don't know the
status of that and how far that's got so
uh that's as much as I know in in
respect to this obviously if that did
come forward it's consideration would be
noise and disturbance of that
development the county would have to
take that into account with its
relationship with all and proposed uh
development along that edge and that's
probably as much as I can give you on
that in terms of the settlement
boundary go back up
here so the um the settlement
boundary currently runs all the way
along internally all around here down
here and back out again um The Joint
local plan shows that essentially the
allocation ends roughly along here I
think it's more detailed in the report
because it's um there's a there's a
comparison between the allocation the
proposal and the previous
proposal and it runs across there so the
extended land here would not currently
be within that
allocation um and
um that's all I can
say
Okay Council pass um thank you Matthew
just a a small question um in the past
we've considered um the risk from heavy
rain and hard standing in driveways and
so on is this the time to look at or is
it possible to put in as a condition if
it were to go ahead that you would like
driveways to be porous I know you
mentioned about Water Resources in here
but that has been a bit of a concern in
the past but equally I understand that
any conditions have got to be
reasonable I would say that layout as a
reserved matter and possibly appearance
because obious materials would be a
matter of you can pick up at reserved
matters it doesn't have to be picked up
at this
point can I just check something um
there was a Sofer waste and minerals
local plan that was um that was because
I I remember starting that work that was
adopted in July 2020 that lists all the
sites so just so there's a new one since
2017 be on the website oh okay that's
the only one came up bear with me I'll
have a look for that just for your just
for your reference I don't know if it's
relevant but I I I remember it well um
okay next up was
uh yeah councelor field I'll come to the
ward members at the end
field uh just on the um summary of
conclusions which is quite a useful
sheet I have to say the points about the
SEC flood team I was struggling to uh
follow it says you they find the flood
risk acceptable but they don't like the
dispos method of disposal of surface
water or sorry that's acceptable but
they do have a holding objection for two
reasons um just just how do I understand
that are we going to change the scheme
in the future or is this it are the
annotations to be added to plans the
solution to their problem because
clearly this uh scheme has quite some
large underground Elements which I
thought would cause problems elsewhere
so I just want to make sure I understand
that um so in respect to the holding
objection um in terms of I've gone over
that in the report but essentially the
uh the point is the county would prefer
in their own preference to have
everything open the whole
lot but this doesn't have everything
open it has the majority of the proposal
to be open studs which swailes and and
everything else all the water runs as an
Open Water System um this does have
crpes uh underground and so some of the
water will be stored under the ground um
so but it's a viable system it'll work
fine what the County's preferen is is
regarding possible maintenance um
because obviously if everything's open
it's probably easier to maintain than if
some of it was enclosed so that's where
their holding objection comes to because
their personal preference is to have
everything open we as a district
council it's never been tested to say
should we refuse something that's not
all open
and as long as the only requirement we
feel we have here in terms of what the
mppf says and what our current policy
position is is a viable sustainable
drainage system that's what we have got
proposed in principle so we have enough
we feel at outline stage to go forward
um the point about preference of whether
it's you have some of underground or not
is a is a point that hasn't really been
tested as as a refusal point so we don't
feel it was appropriate to to pursue
that further okay
so the maintenance cost that the count
is frightened of will fall on the
residents presumably it will fall on to
the landowner or residents yes residents
thank you one other point I note your
analysis of our policies against the
mppf has some like fc1 and
fc11 stated as being out of date but if
I look at a lasater application P page 4
3 it comes to a different
conclusion uh it's basing that decision
on the fact that fc01 and
f1.1 are up to
dat which one is correct the later
application is the uh not as one is it
no the other application is our
application for something in Stone
Market um uh buildings adjacent to
uh let
that so one one's a a district council
application one is the the one we're
currently looking at just uh it was
interesting to see why the analysis is
different I admit I did not realize that
um my only conclusion is that they've
given it more weight in terms of being
in date because it's within the
settlement bound
of Stone Market yes as opposed to
considered to be out of date because
this is partly out well this is outside
the settlement boundary of
elmswell um there is an inconsistency
there that I'd have to take back with me
I can't answer that straight away but my
professional opinion is that they are
out of date in the terms that I've
presented thank
you John I just just just say I found
the report and they have got permission
to extend the quy quite significantly
and it's in the waste
plan
yeah um okay I've no other members so
councelor yeah councelor Matson then
I'll come to the war yeah yeah I I do
have a couple um couple more um yeah I
noticed there was no response in the
papers from the um sustainability
officers um regarding this and I
wondered why that
was and um
yeah I I
don't quite understand why we can't um
Define the housing mix to some degree or
other at this stage um because we seem
to be trying to um do so in the
conditions um a market mix of dwellings
to be agreed um why don't the committee
express some views about um that they'd
like nine Bungalows or something at this
stage I don't quite see the the
[Music]
difference the consultation with
environmental health is up to them if
they come back to us I can't answer any
more than that um in terms of the
housing mix obviously we have sought to
agree the market housing mix part of the
concurrent to the reserve matters so
that we have some say to make sure that
it's appropriate to the housing needs
what you're talking about now is
changing the scale and design at this
stage and defining what that might be
when you have control over that at
Reserve matters so whereas we don't have
control over a number of bedrooms so
that's why we're looking to secure that
with the outline uh in terms of the
market mix number of bedrooms well
Market mix would include number of
bedrooms whereas whether those bedrooms
fit a bungalow whether those bedrooms
fit a house or Department those elements
we would consider the more appropriate
for Reserve matters however there was
nothing members stopping members saying
we only want bungalows in a location
because of say residential amenity uh or
because of some other reason that would
be a matter for your
debate thank you I'm just going to bring
it in
pres thank you chairman just a very
quick Point different point of
clarification I'm sorry I apologize to
Mr Pon G for not asking him before the
meeting um the previous planning
permission from 2018 for 38 dwellings
it's an outline I I note it's reported
as part of the recent planning history I
don't not concerned with anything in the
report but it's an outline more than
three years old I'm presuming it's not
extent not capable of no it has recently
expired so it's not it's not therefore
not there's no fallback position being
reported to members no so that does give
a degree of flexibility over the extra
conditions that have been imposed here
and some of those extra conditions
include uh energy and renewable uh
matters to be agreed prior to the
concurrent uh Reserve matters and it
includes Hedgehog fencing uh it includes
some other things as well those were not
matters that were applied to the 38
houses before okay councilor
Manel uh thank thank you chair I too was
going to ask about the uh expiry of the
previous application um but I do have um
another couple of queries um can you
please clarify the indicative mix of
housing because on one slide you said it
was from one to five bedroom properties
but on the plan which I believe is on
slide eight uh there is no mention of
any five bedroom properties and my
second question is um do you have any
image uh plans of the proposed um
Highway Improvement at the junction just
to remind everybody what is happening at
the dodgy Crossroads with cross street
and new new
Road
I don't have a plan immediately
available to show the highway
improvements um I'm just they are buried
essentially within the transport
assessment I think
um ultimately that matter is to be
secured via the 106 agreement so if the
highways Authority turned around and
said they wanted slightly different to
what's on here we need the flexibility
to allow the highways authority to
change those plans so I have not
presented them as concrete plans um but
they are in the they are in the
transport assessment I'm just double-
checking but they should be in there
um ultimately they're going to be
secured anyway so I've left that as a an
issue the um soorry your second point
was the clarity over the um the the
indicative mix because there is a lot of
um discrepancy between um plans and
lists in the documentation but I believe
the plan you showed us on slide eight
has a list it's called schedule of
accommodation and there are no five
bedroom properties listed in the
indicative mix but on one of your slides
or you mentioned it would be on five
bedroom yeah on the DNA statement there
is a mention of one five-bedroom
property uh but in the later plan that's
gone so the indicative mix is just
saying look we can you know we have
space to put whatever buildings we need
to put here from an outline
perspective that is sufficient from our
point of view we're still essentially
staring at a Red Line Round a site um
the layout the appearance the scale are
all matters reserved the only thing
we've really got is a red line and an
access point
um what we have said said though is in
our recommendation is we have given we
know the affordable housing mix will
eventually be agreed later because that
will be secured by the 106 agreement um
as part of the transfer of the
affordable housing and we have the
proposal that in this case because we're
not entirely clear about the indicative
mix we have the condition to say we will
sort out the housing mix as part of the
reserve matters because we've secured it
by a condition so the answer is we don't
know okay thank you um we'll now move on
to uh the next uh uh sorry we're now
move on to hear from public speakers and
I'm just looking through the list um we
don't have an objection report we have
the parish council so Peter da welcome
uh you have three minutes um and it's
over to you and we have a timer here we
do ask you please to keep to the three
minutes and when you're ready thank you
chair uh the original 2018 permission
was part of a Job Lot from the same
developer centering on his 240 houses on
either side of weather and Road and
they're currently being built out the
core sight of the application before
members today is that 2018 land but
augmented so as to present an extra 2
and a half acres arbitrarily tacked onto
its southern boundary the applican
suggests in seeking justification for
exceptional consideration that this
offers the opportunity of lower housing
density and an easier route to
satisfying the sud's compliance
criteria the glaring a mission in
identifying these benefits is that by
extending the site beyond the original
southern limit it opens up the
opportunity of merging this development
with the applicants of merging weather
and Road Site effectively offering
access to a new housing estate
stretching from Warren Lane across the
open Countryside to link with the
weathered and Road houses indeed the
site layout includes a hammerhead in the
estate clearly prefiguring an
arrangement when this road would lead
into the newer
State the site extension seeks to bring
dwellings closer to the soon to be
extended lawn Farm Quarry already a
noisy and Troublesome neighbor the
acoustic measurements presented here
were taken in 2016 over the intervening
5 years the Quarry operation has been
extended to include for example concrete
crushing on a large scale and your
colleague councelor Stringer has been at
the Forefront of dealing with the
resulting frequent complaints and might
agree that the enforcement of noise
abatement conditions proves in reality
to be
impractical the site extends Way Beyond
any boundaries it is outside of the
emerging jlp allocations it doesn't
feature in the dra neighborhood plan as
being suitable for development it
extends The Village envelope well beyond
the existing boundary the applicant
defines the tree belt to the south of
cres Medway as a woodland cop
it is labeled on the proposed site
layout as a buffer to Countryside it
would pose no impediment to having in
the fullness of time a new estate Road
running through it to link eventually
with weatherton Road my councilors are
aware of the reservations which might be
held by members against refusal of this
application we're also aware of the very
positive outcomes from several recent
decisions to defer final determination
allowing renegotiation towards a more
acceptable outcome not least at school
Road in elmsville I've been asked to
appeal to members that if they do not
see fit to refuse this application
outright then they defer final
determination and ask officers to revert
to the applicant with the suggestion
that a revision back to the original
South Boundary within emerging jlp
allocations is essential otherwise with
absolutely no extenda circumstances
which might benefit the community we're
looking at a decision which would open
the floodgates for future unconstrained
Off plan expansion to the southeast
boundary of our built Village we don't
like that thank you very much uh do we
have any questions to yeah councelor
eban um chair if I may can I ask a
question of the legal um representative
because I'm I'm concerned that we
haven't got any information about the
Quarry the Quarry extension in these in
our papers nor and the fact that the
previous noise limits were 2016 and I'm
I'm concerned about
making a um judge a good judgment based
on noise figures that are five years out
of date when operations have changed
significantly um I mean I I know the S I
live relative you know a few miles away
but I'm just concerned about the
um
uh about the TP the type of judgment we
might make not having that information
yeah I understand the question I wonder
Mr pman G would you like to go first and
then I'll I'll add if necessary to what
you have said
so I am just referring to the
environmental health consultation
responses they don't appear to have
picked up that as a
concern
um our waste manager hasn't picked up
that as a concern either a
quality
so it's not something that has
come into or been highlighted by any of
the consulty responses that we've got
with the exception of the parish
um my my advice and my judgment is that
even with the
expansion you have got the consideration
of the existing part of elmswell closer
in in many respects than this site and a
refusal judged on that that might be
difficult but it's a consideration for
debate yes I I agree me I think the
short answer to councelor EB's question
is the the proper consultations have
been undertaken the responses have been
received and reported to you I think
what what you're saying is you now have
other information that causes you to ask
more questions that's equally
understandable I that's as far as we can
take at this moment I
think okay uh any questions for the
other question any other questions or
questions for the parish
council no okay thank you very much as I
said we don't have um uh an objector or
supporter uh but we'll move straight to
the applicant James Bailey the agent so
over to you and again if you can keep to
three minutes
please here we go thank you very much
good morning chair members uh my name is
James Bailey and I'm the planning
consultant that has been working on the
current proposals on the land that sits
between Warren Lane and Crest Meadow Way
in elmswell I'm joined this morning by
Rick Topman uh who is director at Cannon
Consulting Engineers and between us we
should be able to answer any questions
that you may have with the proposals
we're here this morning to discuss a
site that was previously presented at a
mids planning committee in uh 2018 an
outline application for 38 dwellings on
a slightly smaller Site Area was
presented discussed and agreed with a
decision notice being issued in June
2018 this established that the principle
of development was acceptable in this
location which included mitigation for
its highways impact at the church Road
Crossroads connection to permissive
rights of way to the south of the
village can uh and linking uh new open
space at the nearby Crest development
things have moved forward since this
planning permission was originally
granted the site area and housing
numbers have been Revisited to achieve a
more realistic and feasible layout
whilst at the same time seeking to
improve the landscape setting to the
southern part of the village we are
therefore considering six more dwellings
on just over one hectare of further land
which reduces the overall density from
around 20 and a half to just over 15
dwellings per hectare at the same time
the number of affordable units being
proposed has increased from 13 to 15 we
must also be mindful that the site Now
features within the emerging Babin mids
joint local plan and is identified as
allocation La
a063 therefore as a committed
development with permission there is an
expectation that this site will deliver
housing to elmswell which in turn will
support the growth of the district
detailed pre-application discussions
have taken place with both district and
County Council offices in order to
address the important issues of Highways
and drainage a key part of these
discussions has rightfully focused on
landscaping and open space in order to
achieve something that benefits future
residents whilst also being respectful
of the immediate neighbors it is
considered that the end result is a
highly improved layout from the original
outline permission which will create a
better relationship and integration with
the existing properties of cres Meadow
Way and Warren Lane through adding in
more uh green and Landscape spaces
important details including housing
numbers and mix including Bungalows and
affordables can be secured by condition
if necessary the previously identified
highways improvements will improve
safety at the crossroads and provide
more formalized widening off waren Lane
which will be delivered directly by the
developer as a condition of the
permission in this respect nothing has
changed therefore to conclude the key
question left for members to determine
this morning is does the six additional
houses including two additional
affordable houses on a larger site
resulting in a lower housing density
with significantly improved landscaping
and delivering the same local Road
improvements make for a better scheme
than that which was originally improved
uh approved I therefore respectfully
request that members endorse their
office's recommendation this morning
thank you very much thank you very much
do we have any questions at all yeah can
possible thank you Matthew ju just a
quick one if I may on on the housing mix
um one of the things that I've always
been concerned about uh and this sort of
relates to the affordable housing mix
but it's the opportunity we used to say
young people getting on the housing
ladder I now have to say first time
buyers because it's a debate um and I
just wondered is that would that be incl
because I do think we need to take a bit
of a an approach on this about
sufficient housing for firsttime buyers
I just wonder if you could comment on
that
please if if you're happy for me to to
to to answer that one chair the answer
is yes uh I think uh just to go on
Beyond uh perhaps what the uh the case
officer has presented I think uh one of
the questions and I think uh councelor
Matson has mentioned this it's about
trying to secure uh the the uh the the
mix uh at an early stage this has been
the premise of what we've presented to
uh uh to the authority uh by way of of
the schedule of accommodation and that
is as John rightley says doesn't include
up to five bedroom dwellings it includes
a mix of one-bedroom departments as well
as Bungalows on there and I was going to
to offer to to the chair and to members
here if that was something that people
wanted to secure if it was able to be
done via John uh and and and Ian on
there suitably it is something something
that we would be willing to offer so
that way members know what they are
getting thank you very much any other
questions yes sorry Council mayor chair
not a question but a failure on my part
I um I must declare that I know Mr
Bailey as he lives within my board sorry
about that thank you for that okay yes
councilor
field uh just to seek the developers
view on the noise that uh appears to be
a possible problem from the
Quarry absolutely uh I think uh as
somebody had actually touched upon I
think it might have be even been uh Ian
um when an application goes in uh all of
the statutory consules are given the
opportunity to to comment uh on there uh
I think uh originally uh when the
original application went in I don't
believe that noise uh or or indeed air
quality were raised as an issue back in
20 2018 fast forward three years an
application goes in we have had
pre-application discussions these issues
weren't raised as as an issue uh
identified there the application went in
several months ago I believe uh April uh
May time uh and as we rightly say I
don't believe that we have received any
responses to the country uh that raised
that as a particular issue and that's
that's really all we can say on there
councelor
field councelor mats
thank you yes well the um welcome the
the um the offer to to go a little
further on housing mix um do you think
that the the applicant would accept the
nine which I think the um housing
officers have have suggested of
Bungalows uh and um I'd have to say that
Bungalows is plural so we want at least
two absolutely councilor Masson I think
the the way that I would be describing
this is if members were minded uh and we
were to work forward towards the
indicative plan which again could be
part of uh a potential condition on
there to to work towards achieving the
layout that's set out there um I think
that the uh the the housing mix that set
out on that plan and I think it was
revision D which was the latest version
is exactly the sort of thing that we'd
be able to to work towards which
included as you say a number of
Bungalows on there thank you we
well let's wait till get let's wait till
we get to the debate thank you okay
we're now going to move on as everyone
uh has spoken on that part uh to the two
Ward members so we have councelor Manson
and councelor geek over to you whoever
wants to go
first I think I think that's me I think
I'm going first uh this site this site
was first proposed for Housing
Development back in
2016 uh and was as we've heard from the
parish council promoted by the same
agent as the weathered and road
development of 250 240 houses so I think
it's now 241 uh which is currently about
half completed uh an outline permission
for up to 38 houses was granted in 2018
this has now expired there was much
local opposition to the development uh
back back then due to the some partly
due to the somewhat constrained access
to this site admittedly the site itself
is almost surrounded on all sides by
existing housing so may seem like
somewhere obvious to develop and access
directly from cresm way appears to make
an awful lot more sense than access from
Warren Lane which is a single track Lane
used as a Rat Run particularly to gain
access to the somewhat poorly cited lawn
Farm Business
Park since that outline permission for
38 houses was granted back in 2018
elmswell has been the recipient of much
new development not to mention the
Quarry extension which has already been
discussed 104 new dwellings on Ashfield
Road 241 new homes on weatherton road
both of these developments are on
allocated sites in our draft local plan
but also we have 65 new dwellings as a
phase two to the bacon Factory
development and over and over 25 other
new new dwellings which are on plots
outside of the settlement boundary many
of which were granted when we did not
have a 5-year housing land Supply it is
not as if elmswell needs another six
homes on this site just to boost local
Services we've got plenty already of
course the expansion of elmswell school
has now been agreed to take the school
up to 420 places this still will not
fulfill all the requirements of the
already committed development in the
village and we are still getting many
speculative
applications um for yet more housing
pupils from the six additional dwellings
are not accounted for in the education
requirements and may need to be
transported to schools outside of the
village possibly wpit suffer County
Council are insisting that there should
be some Financial contribution towards
the promised cycle link between the two
Villages but that seems to be um up um
as a obstruction I note that the officer
report states that the density of this
new development is less than that of the
previous 38 but is this necessarily a
good thing the district and Elm as a
village needs more smaller Market
dwellings and we don't necessarily want
another load of large executive homes on
large plots which is what you get with
low density
housing um I'm glad to see that we've
already had some disc discussion about
the uh proposed housing mix on the
indicative plan which does actually show
a good appropriate mix with a number of
smaller
properties um and it could provide us
with much of these much needed smaller
smaller dwellings um so I would welcome
that should this committee be minded to
approve that they do look at uh some
conditioning of the mix of housing but
we do need to be clear on what we're uh
agreeing to because there are some
errors in the numbers in the various
documents that we've got on the um on
this
application uh it would also be good if
these more of these new homes could be
oriented to make the most of solar gain
and were heated by Renewables rather
than gas should this committee be minded
to approve I hope that you will consider
these suggestions as well as other
conditions relating to The Pedestrian
access to the site the fo path links
from the site to both Warren Lane and
cres Meadow Way should be cycleways not
just foot paths the most obvious route
from these new homes to the primary
school would be via the cres meow way
access and that so that really does need
to be a cycle link uh I'd also like you
should you be minded to approve to
condition the footpath link shown on the
indicative plans in the south of the
site to create a link to some permissive
footpaths which give access to the wider
footpath Network to the south of the
village much used by dog walkers and
others uh particularly since the covid
lockdowns there also needs to be a
condition relating to proposed play
areas and public open space provision
which I couldn't quite see on the list
um and and and also something to do with
the drainage um uh to make sure that
those also comply with what we've got in
our indicative mix and it does appear
that the agent is willing to concede on
some of these um these conditions thank
you thanks very much councelor
geek thank you chair um I would like to
Echo and support the objections raised
by councelor Manel and by alel Parish
Council the extension to the South
beyond the allocated site in the draft
joint local plan and not just slightly
larger but half as big again uh will set
an unfortunate precedent it will
encourage further sprawl into the
countryside towards that noisy Quarry in
addition the many objections that were
received uh by the council at the time
of the previous application and which
are still relevant if not more relevant
to this one seem to have been rather
overlooked and those objections came
from Al elmswell and wetherden Parish
councils and from several residents in
both parishes they mainly referred to
traffic considerations around Warren
Lane um since since uh that time it now
has to accommodate increased traffic
resulting from the development of the
lawn Farm industrial estate um and many
housing developments in the area now I
know that none of you will need
reminding that elmswell still has no
improvements to its Junctions with the
A14 so anyone want wanting to use Warren
Lane still has to go uh from the A14 has
to go either through woolpit past the
primary school and the Health Center or
through Harley New Street and wetherden
or through the School Road Junction in
elmswell which I'm sure you you could
live the rest of your lives happily
without ever hearing about again you
must all be horribly familiar with it
the county highways team appear only to
have considered the immediate effects on
Warren Lane but as we all know once you
get into your car you're unlikely to go
just as far as the next Road so please
do think of the bigger picture uh lastly
approving yet another small increase to
the population of the village means that
the decision to approve the extension to
the current Primary School site looks
ever more like an expensive but
extremely short-term sticking plaster
but in common with other commentators if
you're minded to approve this
development do please include those
conditions firstly the previous outline
consent the 38 houses one stipulated
that an energy scheme be approved prior
to commencement which covers water
energy and other resource efficiency
measures uh will heat pumps be specified
for instance rather than gas boilers
putting Energy Efficiency in at an early
Point seems essential to me in this time
of climate crisis relying on the warm
words uh in the design and access
statement is unlikely to be enough um
secondly uh and related at present on a
rough count around 10 of the dwellings
on the indicative plan lack a
south-facing roof now that's better than
many recent appliations but still it
could be improved please could there be
an expectation that the final layout
either improves the number of roofs that
could be used for solar panels or at the
very least doesn't reduce them um and
lastly the offer to condition the
housing mix is welcome most particularly
the Bungalows are important and the
numbers of larger houses should not be
increased thank you very much any
questions for the ward
members nope okay so members uh we've
had all the information put before us
it's now up to us to debate and come to
a
conclusion who's going to go first
councel
reburn I'm not sure why everyone is so
unwilling to speak um today um I I this
is an interesting application and I
think that I think it's a shame it is
being discussed as being six more it's
not six more it's a it's a site for 44
houses there is no current permission
for this site and I think we need to
ensure that all our debate and
discussions are based on a site of 44
houses and now a lot has changed since a
previous um application um was put
forward in 2016 not least we now have a
5year housing land Supply in fact we now
have nearly a 10year housing land Supply
um and so there's a lot of policy
changes and I think it's a shame that
that has not been um put forward to date
within um the information before
us there's also been changes in um the
surrounds for the area notably um the
the Quarry um the increase um the change
of the work there that it does much
different work now than it did in
2016 um and the Planned extension for it
and I'm very disappointed that um that
has not been included um within our
papers and within the um discussions to
date um similarly um since the original
application was put in there's been an
granting of um land for a primary school
in wpit to service the ever growing
population of elmswell and again I'm
surprised that the there's is even a
debate about not securing funding for a
foot path and cycle link um to warit um
not least um many people use elmswell
train station and it would be um helpful
for that let alone for children going to
and from um school
safely there's also given this is a site
for 44 houses and mentions in the in the
um conditions um about highways
improvements at um Church Road and um
cross street and there is no mention of
that um in in the or details of that
here
um I think with regards to the um
comments that have been made so far um
we we've been advised recently that we
do need to um we are able to secure the
numbers for housing mix um and the types
so particularly Bungalows and so on and
I think we that must be included in in
the conditions and I think the um foot
cycle path as the County Council have
requested um should be included um but
at the moment um um chair I'm not happy
about this partly
because just the fact that it isn't six
more houses it is it is a site for 44 it
stretches beyond the settlement boundary
beyond the draft joint local plan
settlement boundary into the country
side we've got a nearly 10-year housing
land Supply um that that can is vastly
changed from when this was first
proposed and I'm not very happy about it
at the moment but I'll wait to see what
my fellow um members say Thank you very
much thanks so much councelor maton was
next thank you yes I I think the the um
the the news that I must I hadn't
spotted that the the 38 had lapsed um we
are therefore dealing with a new
application and the
previous two or three applications that
that councilor Manel was referred to um
have all contributed to the path to link
the two Villages and as the county has
set out particularly clearly in the late
papers the the linkage between these two
Village the mutual support that's
provided um per by the the health center
which they share then the railway
station that they share we're being
asked to to accept um a greater degree
of sharing of of Education provision
between the two at primary level than
than we we would welcome and certainly
that the world members would welcome H
and um so really I I cannot support
anything that does not contribute to
with that desperately needed completion
of that path safe walking and cycling
between the two Villages so I I can't
you know I setting everything else that
we might want to talk about aside for
that reason I I can't support it at this
stage
just going to bring in John pman G at
this
point just a couple of points um in
terms of the expired application it
would be incorrect to say it has no
material weight you can give it less
material weight because it has expired
but I would also caution you there
because it only recently expired and the
polic policy position of the council
hasn't changed that much we do have the
same local plan we still have the same
core strategy and and and uh Focus
review the nppf has changed um and been
updated uh July this year was the latest
um I would also just caution you in
respect of the housing Supply the
allocation of 38 houses is part of that
calculation so you you can't exclude it
or I suggest you don't exclude it
because it's part of that calculation
because all the allocations across the
district are part of that um uh Supply
the cycle path just to point out the
reason why this is causing us
difficulties if I'm being perfectly
honest is it's not in the allocation in
your emerging joint local plan it's in
the allocation of all the other sites in
elmswell but not this one now that might
be a glaring error that policy team need
to pick up but if we are giving any
weight to that it is the current
position we have to consider um however
that said as I said at the beginning of
my presentation at the end of my
presentation a review in respect to the
county requirements is part of the
situation now uh that we are
recommending uh that we carry out uh
with the county
officers thank you for that uh Council
pmore um thank you chairman um yeah this
is a difficult application to look at
and I have listened to all the arguments
in great
detail and um I think that on balance I
would like to propose that we we do
accept it but with some conditions
because one of the um items that's been
mentioned I accept this is an outline
stage and that is the housing mix now
I'm not quite sure how we word that but
I raised the issue with the applicant
regarding starter homes we've obviously
had discussions about Bungalows
affordable housing and so on so if you
could word that as a condition um that
that that is to be agreed I think the
planning team would clearly understand
where where I was coming from on that I
know I mentioned drainage and permeable
um driveway and so on clearly that's for
the reserved matters and I do wonder
whether we can put some words in there
regarding the um pedestrian cycle Wass
to the to the other Village I think John
was saying that's perhaps one for review
but I do think that needs to be
referenced so that that can be looked at
practically and I do agree that a
previous application of course it has a
material consideration because it's um
quite recent I do accept it's a bigger
site of course it is um but I think it
has been well well thought out and I do
still have concerns about about the
Quarry but I'm prepared to take the uh
the words that we've heard there that um
it may not be um a reason for for
refusal so with that chairman I am um
proposing as I say it's a difficult um
one to to decide this but with that with
those extra conditions regarding the uh
cycle ways and pedestrian ways the
housing mix I think is really really
important that we do everything possible
for firsttime buyers as well as the
other parts of the affordable um
conditions we've also mentioned a play
area I've written that down that needs
to be in there as well I think um but
happy to listen to the rest of the
debate and take on any suggestions
should that be necessary thank you for
that council humre is do next Mr
chairman thank you um I sort of agree
with um councilor re burn on some points
and also Council pmore on others um the
outline permission for 38 houses
obviously we passed that it's obviously
just gone out of date but it still has a
bearing on what we're doing today this
is an expansion um an expansion to the
South that provides an extra six houses
but the great thing about that is that
it reduces the density of that estate
and that is really really good because
the previous application I thought was
quite tight and actually when you look
at the pictures on page the indicted
plan on
page the page is covered but just above
3.3 um it only shows 19 properties on
there it doesn't give a true reflection
of what we were expecting before um so
if we had the 38 houses there it' be
really tight so I think this is great in
the fact that um it allows for that uh
less dense um development
um there's more open space as well which
is a benefit which is quite nice and
actually I've looked through par Point
4.3 where it talks about the vehicle uh
vehicular access to Warren Lane and The
Pedestrian access to Warren Lane and
creme cremo way a pedestrian access to
cres meow way was not included in the
previous plan but is now so there are
improvements I do get the conditions
you're seeking actually reference um
pedestrian and traffic and and I'd
support those um it's really refreshing
to see the applicant taking notes um and
rare um so you're taking notes and I
noticed you were doing it when the ward
members were talking and you've already
commented on the fact you're willing to
do some more work so the reserve matters
I'm expecting something spectacular if
uh if we get approval today my major
concern was the Quarry um as you said
the policy changed and they have got an
expansion permission and my concern was
where is that expansion going in which
direction because it's going Northwest
and we're actually expanding the
previous application down to the
southeast that makes it closer um Mr P J
like you come back on that if you would
and I'll come back thank
you um I apologize for not having enough
on this particular Point um however
let's see if I can make up for it um um
is there Bandy is there any way I can
pass you a picture to put on
screen it's the extract from the local
plan of the mineral minerals and waste
it shows the area that's been allocated
for the expansion not easily okay
essentially the the uh expansion well
okay put my presentation back on if you
could
okay
right let's see if I
can so effectively if you can see the um
the outline there of the green Edge
between the two greens but one lighter
than the other one's darker is that
clear to everybody yeah right so the
expansion runs along that edge there and
it essentially continues all the way
across Ross to that point there so that
entire area if I just do that is
allocated as potential expansion and
part of that been given permission but
essentially all of that is is the
expansion Zone uh for the Quarry um the
extract I've got here in terms of their
assessment of that
says
um there are a number of Residential
Properties to the north of the which lie
within 250 M of the extension site
boundary properties are M Gardens and
pres sorry Prescott Drive the closest
property is Warren Mill House which is
approximately 100 m from the extension
boundary this property is no closer to
the extension boundary than it is to the
existing Quarry boundary and a Bund is
already in place to separate the
property from the extraction
activities a standoff buffer is
indicated on the drawings which which
includes a screening bond which could be
easily installed as further mitigation
if
required the rest it goes on about
traffic movements and other things
that's probably about the best
information I can give you if you need
more then it might be a point to defer
for another day if if you need more
information on
that thank you um so this is where I
might be going because um with that
explanation you just provided that
expansion takes it very very close to
this um planned outline plan permission
I mean really
close that's the problem that I've got
the major
problem if I may count of that it also
brings it very close to all of elmswell
um and ultimately it essentially
stabilizes this entire southern side of
elmswell if if if we considering that
but all I can say to you is the
consultation responses I've got do not
indicate that as a problem and the
county have gone ahead with that
expansion despite the going closer to
elmswell as part of their
allocation well I think in light of that
information chairman I'd like to
withdraw my recommendation change it to
defer it because I think this is quite a
serious issue because we need to have
this clarified I would have thought
because if we make a decision and say
yes or no or whichever way we go and we
haven't taken that properly into account
I mean I think I think I think and I
don't know John I just can I just
summarize I I think the problem is that
that Quarry has now got permission to
expand there's nowhere in the papers
that talks about the impact of the
expansion on the new site okay it may
impact the existing houses but we're not
here today to discuss the existing
houses we're here to discuss the
planning application so we are
immediately if we're not careful and the
concern I have is we're giving
permission to housing that on day one of
occupation is going to be impacted
potentially by an expanded site and how
do those two sit together and we haven't
really got an answer to that except to
say no one has responded which doesn't
really sit comfortably probably well it
doesn't with me and I suspect with other
members if if we had a letter absolutely
outlining the expansion is fine we're
happy that we don't think it's a problem
but we're not getting that we just
haven't got comment on it I think the
problem is I'm not quite sure what
information I can get you on that if I'm
honest you we can have someone an expert
create a a kind of assumption of what
the noises might be and guess at what
that relationship of that site down the
hill versus this site would might be but
I I'm not sure how we assess the noise
of a quar and the
expansion in that context I would have
to talk to the county because maybe they
have obviously more expertise available
but
I have to go away and find that out I'm
not entirely sure how to put together
something that gives gives you the
information you need are you concerned
about the noise of the quarry on the
residence despite the allocation goes so
far out already it's the extra bit of
land or is it the entire site and the
allocation is is in threat so it it
there's lots of factors here I'm not
quite
sure how to go forward
on does it blight the site I'm not I'm
not a mineral extraction expert I don't
suppose anybody is it but I do actually
think you if if you able to find out a
lot more information cuz making a
however difficult and challenging I'm
obviously not blaming you you for that
but we do need to have a full
understanding of what the implications
may or may not be um and nothing to do
with this site but if you think of
what's happened with English China clay
and their extraction of China clay down
in Cornwell and different Zach make
different context but the principle is
still the same will you be getting dust
and dirt and so on I and I I just don't
know but I do think In fairness to the
ACT applicant the residents and
everything we really do need a some sort
of detailed assessment of that from the
County Council I'd imagine they would
have to have done that assessment aart
with regard to the both the allocation
and any yes but not with the expanded s
well has the expanded site got
permission is a question so therefore
it's in the document it's all approved
it's in it's in the development plan but
it's not has it got planning
permission yes it has right so on that
basis your colleagues my my colleagues
in planning and development control of
County have already carried out an
assessment on that expansion site and
how it affects the surrounding area so
extrapolating that we would have to go
back over that to see how that affects
this site I think I think I think
otherwise otherwise the the committee
then has to decid whether the Cory is
such a powerful impact that it thinks
should be refused is is that what you're
saying but essentially their assessment
on their planning appli application
would have taken into account the
allocation site anyway because that's
part of the uh emerging joint local plan
so the only real section is is the
expanded section of this site that needs
to be further looked
at just going I'm just going to bring in
back I've got a few yeah I've got a few
more speakers that want to come in now
hum you want finish off thank you Mr
chairman thank you John for you come
back on that and also thank you
councilor pasmore for going back for
referal um I'd just like to maybe add a
little bit that you might have all that
information or rather people above you
in the county and everything else got
that information they may have done
those assessments the facts are we
haven't got that information and that's
the information we need sh us the
evidence sh us the information then we
can make a proper decision until there
our second
deferral does anyone else yes yep counc
Reb counc Madison um we got a proposal
in a second if a defer on those reasons
thank you chair um the on the I've just
looked up the waste and mineral site and
it says housing developers are advised
they should provide adequate m m
mitigation in respect of the permitted
sand and gravel Quarry and I think it's
not just noise it's noise and dust I
think as Council of par more referred to
with the China clay dust is a big issue
as well sorry I brought you in totally
out of order because actually councelor
field was next and councelor mayor
but counc pH Council may do you want to
come and add anything before we make it
that decision on there's a sore
temptation to say the same thing in
different words every time isn't there I
think one is I I'm really concerned
about the the the Quarry clearly um this
site is a lot closer to the Quarry than
the pre previously approved application
and clearly it's appropriate to to defer
while we we uh investigate that it's
obviously quite technically possible to
measure what noise and dust the current
Quarry generates and serate that see
whether at the sort of distances this
will be be bearable or not so I think
I'm totally for deferring and uh finding
those the answers to those issues I'll
have to say I do quite like the expanded
layout here that does seem better for
the people who will subsequently will
live in this development I do think the
things that um the world member raised
the issues about footway links and Cycle
Way links to the School uh need to be
resolved I do think we need a condition
that says you should we decide
ultimately to go ahead that the uh the
layout and housing um allocation be
essentially in accordance with the
outline but uh it's absolutely critical
that we uh investigate the Quarry issue
first thank you thanks and Council mayor
my
apologies thanks chair um very quickly
very happy to support the deferral um
for me the issue on the site is is the
extension Justified is the extension
beyond the allocated site Justified and
there are clear
benefits but there are clear benefits
that as yet have not been secured so
what will worry me is we agree the
extension then suddenly the layout
changes so if we are in the future going
to agree this I would want to see those
benefits tied in so that we have some
control over the dwellings you know 44
five bedroom houses is that possible
because the out outline um proposal
outline permission may say in the future
44 well we need to actually secure the
Bungalows because that's the benefit the
improved layout
is a better delivery for the people of
elmsville so um happy to defer or
support deferral but I would want to see
the benefits sec ured in any future um
application okay well I think we've got
a proposal for deferral and a second a
proposed by councilor parore second by
councel hum I oh sorry yeah yeah I I
wanted to to ask I mean I I you know
agree with the deferral um but C can can
we ask officers to to negotiate um some
more detailed conditions with the
applicant regarding mix the the part
payment towards the path and the
sustainable design response that we
haven't got back yet can we can we ask
officers to look for those things as
well please okay well that's they've
heard you so we'll see that's see if
they can pick that
up well it we we're just deferring it
for that can be part of the reasoning
that we'd like more information but the
main reason is to do with the
Quarry
yeah okay um on that basis I think we
better go to a electronic vote please
thank you chair members your vote reads
the application number DC
22956 be deferred to allow officers to
obtain further information regarding the
expansion and Associated issues with the
adjacent
Quarry that vat is now in
progress
thank you members chair that's seven
votes for
deferral okay thank you and just to just
for clarity Council Manel although she's
sitting amongst us couldn't vote on that
item as the ward member
exactly thank you very much okay so that
item is Def bir um I propose we take a
quick uh break and we start again at 5
11 could I just ask those that are
leaving seats if you could kindly just
wipe them down with the um with the uh
sanitizing sheets that would be helpful
because other people will be coming into
those seats we'll start again at 5 P
thank
you
okay so welcome back uh we now move on
to the next item on the agenda uh which
is uh item
7B uh which is the
application uh
uh DC 2103
589 uh in stonum so over to you John
you're going to take us through
this yes so unfortunately the case
officer wasn't able to present this one
but um I have decided to present it um
given that it has come to members
previously so this is land to the rear
uh of the Le uh Star Mall uh it's an
application for the approval of reserved
matters uh following the grant of
outline permission uh for for five
houses and these are the reserve
matters the uh the reserve matters being
appearance landscape uh layout and
scale so the
um the previous applic well this
application was uh looked at by members
uh in uh beginning of November uh you
resolved to defer the determination to
seek an expert Heritage assessment and
review uh we went back to our heritage
team and they have come back to us with
an updated response which is part of
your
papers um and essentially what they now
say is that the proposal would cause a
low to medium level of less than
substantial harm to the setting and
significance of the grade two listed
Orchard Farmhouse if I just click over
to hopefully a location
plan which is the property uh indicated
there which is just there
the proposed dwellings are would be
fairly prominent intrusions to the
historic historically rural character of
the setting of Orchard Farmhouse which
contributes to its significance it
recommends they recommend that the scan
design of the dwellings is revised to
reduce the level of harm as far as
feasible instead this now forms the
basis of the recommendation and the
change of recommendation by officers to
refusal and that is before you
today essentially the PowerPoint
presentation is the same as previously
presented and I will just run through
that quickly this is the
site in terms of
the right this is the
site uh the outline the red line there
is the site the official location plan
and obviously you've got a property
there that would be removed in order to
create an
access and this is the proposed
layout and these are the various
elevations of The
Proposal all of these are was in your
papers and we also have an attenuation
scheme beyond the application
site
just to indicate this is the outline
indicative plan uh but of course it was
indicative um and of course there's no
reason why you can't change uh various
aspects that weren't
reserved were
reserved so we have here the previous
refusal um which is in your planning
history on one side with the c proposal
on the
other and we have the photographs just
showing you the existing uh residential
location and I think that's Orchard
Farmhouse for
memory and just looking out onto the
site
itself uh the barn in the background
there is probably a good indication of
the site when you look at the areal
photographs as a
comparison
I think that's a view from the list of
building
itself I just jump back to the proposed
layout
there so the proposal is considered
acceptable in all other respects except
for the harm to the list of building
and the public benefit to the scheme
despite the outline permission in
principle is not considered to outw
outweigh the harm of the appearance
layout scale and Landscaping of the
scheme before members at this time and
therefore the recommendation is refusal
as per your
papers thank you very much okay um
obviously this came before us before and
we sent it away further information that
information's come back uh with this
recommend change of recommendation any
uh comments or any questions at this
stage no okay thank you um now uh we do
have uh the parish council's here but
not wanting to speak I understand but we
do have an objector Beverly Brady
welcome um and you have three minutes
and if you could keep to the three
minutes please thank you chairman
representing 1 two three and five quits
Meadow Longshore Orchard Farm and the
landowner who Farms immediately by
behind the site we believe the
application should be rev refused for
the following reason one Reserve matters
not in accordance with outline planning
permission in our opinion the revised
plans represent an unacceptable 50%
increase in scale and appearance which
we consider must be a material change
these monstrous size properties are out
of character with qu's Meadow instead of
a bungalow weed be overshadowed by an
oppressive five-bedroom two-floor
dwelling with matching height garage
this this fails to add value to the mix
of local housing where the need in our
secondary Village is for housing which
is Affordable not massive 4 and five
bedroom houses the drainage basin Still
Remains outside the redline area
integral and needs separate approval two
impact of significance on the Heritage
asset we're pleased to see the full
response from Heritage has now been
received and continues to raise the same
concerns as per all the previous failed
applications and as to its potential
harm the report States the proposed
dwellings would be prominent intrusions
into the historically rural character of
the setting of Orchard Farm also that
the decision takers should be mindful of
their D duties to the desirability of
preserving the listed building or its
setting and it comments further
regarding a further reduction to scale
and design this application has to be
refused three impact on res residential
amenity how the idea of an access road
cut through the of our small cisac isn't
considered significant is frankly
depressing the relocation of the
contractor's compound to slap bang
between three and five queep Meadow
unacceptable and this must be cited
within the fold yard to minimize the
already considerable disruption noise
and harm to near neighbors equally the
sighting of the bin store as an
unsightly addition to the middle of our
C deac completely unacceptable and
unnecessary if the access road was
genuinely adequate our own secluded
setting the boundary and part being the
wall of the Lees would be gone
devastating and a risk to both our
security and privacy little or no detail
provided on how this would be
rectified the responsibility for the
upkeep of the new open areas either side
of the access rows were previously
glossed over again unsatisfactory for
those in Ko's Meadow who would be
directly impacted to a far greater
extent than those residing in the new
complex the amount of land already
available should be a prime
consideration against this speculative
Green Field application whilst the
properties may be considered by some as
attractive not so for existing residents
when considering their scale and impact
thank
you thanks very much uh any questions at
all yes Council mson yeah c can um Can
officers show us where where this um
site compound is wasn't clear that the
um well I didn't see a plan that showed
me where it was but I might have missed
it um
P
two all
right read
it 204 slide
14 okay so it's that Wheel Wash
Etc okay um so we
um the we don't have a supporter but the
agent has sent an email um uh following
this application do you just want to
comment because they have asked if
something can be read out at the meeting
but I don't know how appropriate it is
so I'll leave that to the officers to
determine um chairman yes um I the
emailing question went to to you Mr
chairman and I think and the vice
chairman to to yourself and and indeed
yes uh John first and I'll finish is it
not a normal practice to specifically
read out things from the agent in that
context but I will mention that it is a
complaint it has been given to the
complaints proced uh complaints team and
the basic basis of the complaint is that
they feel that uh governance has not
been carried out correctly in that's not
correct we have given the 5 days
publication time for the report but they
feel it was short notice um they also
feel that the change of uh
recommendation is unacceptable and
obviously that's their judgment and that
would be a matter to be picked up by the
complaints team as necessary there is
nothing in my opinion of any bearing
that needs to be brought forward to this
committee to determine the merits of the
applic ation before us thank you very
much okay so um we now move to the ward
member uh who has written
in so I'll just run through that
councelor Susie moley my comments are
substantially the same as I gave at the
previous planning meeting on where this
where this was deferred and I'm glad to
see the revised opinion of our heritage
team and would concur with their opinion
this application must be refused A
previous application for reserved
matters on this site DC
23291 was refused because the
application was not in accordance with
the outlined planning permission impact
on significant significance of Heritage
asset an impact on residential immunity
the current application continues to
fail on these grounds reserved matters
are not in accordance with outline
planning permission the proposed scale
of this development is 60% bigger than
that indicated at outline planning stage
the single story houses indicated have
all been replaced by large two-story
properties
there has therefore been a significant
increase in scale and change in building
types this materially Alters the basis
of the decision to Grant outline
planning permission and is clearly not
in accordance with the outline planning
permission it should not be possible to
consider such a significant larger scale
proposal under a reserved matters
application further Planning Commission
should be required for such a proposal
and this current application should be
refused the proposal include and relies
upon unapproved development outside the
agreed R line area the current plan
indicate the construction of an
unapproved large intervention pool with
Associated drainage systems and a
potentially permanent contractor's
Compound on agricultural land outside
the red line see document 207
4695 an engineering
layout
473g proposed on site plan ground and
others these will have significant
impact in last in damage to the natural
environment and surface water
characteristics of the land as well as
on the setting and significance of the
nearby listed building the proposed
intervention Pond is fed by drains from
the proposed development and as such as
an engineering operation that forms an
integral part of the proposed
development it cannot be considered to
be agricultural work it should therefore
require planning permission the Heritage
officer gave detailed reasons for
refusal of the previous application
which were accepted and summarized by
the chief planning officer in the
refusal decision the current application
does not mitigate the harm to the
setting and significance of the grade to
listed Orchard Farm and the public
benefits of the proposed development do
not outweigh the level of harm to the
setting and significance of this
Heritage asset these remain
architecturally massive as twostory
five-bedroom properties with a 6.5 meter
Ridge height far removed from the small
three-bedroom Bungalow shown in the
approved indicative plan plan this
current proposal places these massive
properties just as close to Orchard Farm
as the refused application and worsens
the situation by moving the two double
height double garages to sit
approximately 10 meters nearer to the
listed building than they were in the
refused plan the village are not against
development as can be seen from their
willingness to engage and support a
larger application on the other side of
the road the village are all in favor of
appropriate development to support our
resid
however this application is not
appropriate in a hinan village please
reject this District's Council Susie
moley ward council of stonum Ward and
resident of stonum
aspel
okay so um that's the information before
us uh over to us to discuss debate and
come to a conclusion Council eurn then
councel humph um thank you chair um I
know that everyone on this committee has
been through this application in detail
at the last um committee meeting um and
I think it just shows the Merit of the
committee asking for all the information
to be included um in the applications um
that we consider um and um I would be
happy to um propose recommendation of um
refusal in line with the officer's
recommendation um but I'd ask that they
um if there are further discussions with
the applicant they review what's
happening with the attenuation Pond but
that's a request that they can take up
or not thank you very much Council humph
Mr chairman thank you keep it short and
sweet uh no real change here we were
right to defer we were right to seek
that further information on Heritage
officer it's come back there's still a
low to medium risk of harm that
designated heritage heritage asset and
therefore I will second that proposal
for refusal thank you very much
councilor pmo nothing to add I'll you
support the uh the proposal counc Manel
uh thank you chair uh I too will will
support the the current proposal um but
I just like to to comment on some of the
uh things that the ward member mentioned
in her in her written response or
whatever you want to call it um is that
you
know the as we've just seen as we've
just discussed in previous applications
what you see in the outline of five
small Bungalows is not what you're going
to get the outline permission is for
five up to five dwellings with the
Demolition of the um one that the access
goes through so unfortunately we've got
the outline permission something is
going to go on that plot and let's hope
that the next time we have something
that's slightly more appropriate but you
know five dwellings are five dwellings
much as we'd like them all to be small
Bungalows um they're they're not going
to be probably but let's hope we get
something that is a more appropriate
scale at the next iteration thank you
thank you very much um that's everyone
that wish yes Council
mayor thank you was I'm very happy to
support the proposal I'm a little bit
confused as to why the reasons for
refusal on P page 182 of the the um
previous Reserve matters have dropped
off
um ref reason for refusal Reserve
matters not in accordance with outline
planning permission well I think that
still extand reason for refusal impacts
on a Heritage asset well that's still
there on the the refusal this time
reasons for refusal impact on
residential imunity I don't think
anything's changed and I think they
should be part of the um refusal thank
you John can you comment on
that I have brought this funny enough I
brought this up in my brief because the
recommendations obviously on page 224
are minimal and then there is at the
bucket it says see a pended decision for
those already imposed so the question is
do the previous ones are they imposed on
this or should we specify
them the only refusal officers are
recommending are the harm to the listed
building um I'm just reviewing the
previous review is the scheme I haven't
got that in front of
me
um the problem with the there's a
technical issue with the previous
refusal because it was about the access
and the access has already been approved
under the
outline so trying to change the access
the previous refuser was trying to
change the access and I think that was
the issue and technically that's not the
case this time around so I wouldn't want
to reapply that um so that's condition
that was reason one on page 184 that
correlates with what papers are in front
of
members
sorry um I thought the previous um
application that was refused was that
they weren't going to demolish the house
next to the access so actual fact it was
one effectively a net gain of one
dwelling the outline was for knocking
knocking the house down in building five
and wasn't the last refusal not knocking
it down so reason one refers to that
that doesn't apply this time around the
other issue was something to do with the
access on reason one as well so
essentially reason one of that refusal
isn't applicable to this application so
we can take that one off um in terms of
Heritage asset harm well we've got that
one still in play that's what we're put
forward to you now that just leaves me
with reason free which is impact on
residential amenity
um
that's the close proximity of the
proposed access road to the two but the
access road is still is part of the
outline in terms of the access point
that can't
change access through the two the access
road going through the two so if is it
in your judgment if we can just have the
layout back on screen if you don't
mind could we just put the PowerPoint
back on please if we may
sorry so that's helpful right so in
terms of the access point that is a a
matter that's already been dealt with by
the outline but in terms of the access
going through does that materially harm
the amenity of neighbors given its where
else would you put it but because
ultimately it's equal distance to the
two neighbors if you're going to put it
one side going around here it will
affect that neighbor if you put it over
here it'll affect this neighbor more
that might be difficult to defend in my
opinion
um but I think possibly the access road
might have been about when it was on the
previous refusal because there was a
property there and I think that was
about that so in essentially the the
amenity issue or is different for that
last refusal would not probably be
applicable to this application unless
there isn't any other amenity issues
members wish to put forward so at the
moment I'm satisfied that harm to the
list of building is our main point
Council mayor do you want to come back
merely to say that you know the smaller
buildings have morphed into larger
buildings you know is that not um a
significant change to the
outline unfortunately an outline is a
Red Line Round the site uh scale
appearance layout were not part of that
outline so as much as it is a change in
terms of was indicative it is not
different to what officially the outline
Planning Commission gave permission
for however you want to come in your
judgment is if the scale layout
appearance now is appropriate or not and
if you feel it's inappropriate for
whatever reason that's your debate you
we're say it's inappropriate because of
the list of building if you're thinking
it's inappropriate for any other reason
I'll leave that with
you I would suggest that the the large
five bedroom house are inappropriate and
so I would say the scale is too large in
my personal
opinion counc do you want to come in
then we'll go to councelor eurn and
councel humre who are proposing I was
going to make a similar point that uh
much of the debate has been about scale
and we are justifiable in looking at
scale and the view is that the scale is
not what we were expecting having seen
the outlaw permission
so I feel something about scy is
appropriate coun Evan hum how do you
want to play that so your you've
proposed and seconded if there's an
appropriate sorry excuse me if there's
an appropriate um planning reason to
include for scale then I'd be happy to
add that um if councelor Humphrey is in
agreement with me thank you chair Mr
chair yeah I am and I think scale has an
impact any on the Heritage asset so so
it's all linked
yeah so your reason for refusal at this
moment does pick up on scale and
character but mostly in relation to the
harm to a listed building are you
telling me that you are saying that in
terms of the rural character of the
locality it is it is also out of keeping
yes good right so on that basis perhaps
we would add that line into the reason
for refusal that we've got that not only
I'll to find the appropriate point to
put that
um so we've already we're already saying
CS5 uh to talk about the environment but
CS5 also puts picks up on the character
of the
locality
uh
R character the setting of the grade to
listed and harm to it character I would
simply put actually at the very so
essentially if you're looking at the
reason for refusal on page
140 um on the second paragraph it says
uh to the setting of grade to listed
Orchard Farmhouse and harm to its
character I would also just put in
essentially an outter keeping with the
surrounding area to the end of
that would that be sufficient
I'll do that just say on our papers it's
page 138 just so there's two pages out
different numbering between the
electronic and the paper so anyone on
paper with page
[Music]
138 okay so on that basis we will go to
a vote
um and there been proposed by Council
eurn seconded by Council Humphrey's CLA
can you just remind us the finer detail
that we're voting on
please the vote actually reads chair as
sprad out by the area plan manager John
has to spread that
out thank you that vote is now in
progress
this
lost
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for
refusal
okay thank you very much okay so we'll
move uh swiftly on to the next
application can I just ask if anyone's
clearing a seat if you could just wipe
it and if the people for the next
application want to come forward to the
seats
one is uh straber and
laxfield
barley Brig Farm is
next
prime minister's M to make an
announcement apparently on uh further
restrictions apparently but anyway we'll
wait and see if we hear
anything
uh that's not appropriate this time okay
so we'll move swiftly on swiftly on to
planning application dc21
02047 uh this is in uh the ward of strab
Brook and laxfield and I hand over to
the case officer Daniel Cameron to take
us through
it thank you
apologies members bear
with um yes this application was
previously brought before members on the
15th of September um at that meeting um
there was concern raised about the
precise wording of conditions suggested
within the officer's report um the
update report gives you full wording of
those conditions members um you'll note
that in the um original report there are
seven bullet points relating to seven
conditions and there are six sections
within the updated report the noise
conditions I've just put into one
section so there are still seven
conditions recommended members I've just
put those together for
you
okay so the site is barley Brig Farm um
there's quite a considerable planning
history on this site and and much of it
has been before um members of planning
committee um we have the anerobic
digestion site to the north um
previously this year we've dealt with a
ground Source heat pump installed in the
fields to the north of the site we have
some existing Piggery buildings we have
an existing barn on the site already
that was approved in
2008 we see the
wider context of the site is
agricultural
as we come down here we have the red
line for the application site and the
application site concerns the
construction of a
barn on this plot of
land in terms of constraints we
relatively unconstraint members we have
a grade two listed building some
distance away however it's considered
too far away to really materially affect
consideration of the application before
us so here we are we have an existing
storage building on the site and then we
have the footprint of the new barn
adjacent there are two um barns
previously approved on that site members
one in
2017 was for a large barn similar in
size to the one you see before you today
um that one could not be used for the
purposes of drying grain or crop there
is a second um Barn approved on that
site in 2019 which can be used for the
grying drying of grain and crop and is
much much smaller than the um bar we
have before us
today in terms of elevational treatment
it's a fairly standard agricultural
building obviously of a size to allow it
to operate a you know suitable
commercial
level and then internally we
have a barrier area so we have an area
for grain drying and we have another
area as well and we have some uh first
floor
um activity within the barn as well to
deal with plant and members will see
that from the wording of the condition
that that is approvable but in line with
the comments of the parish council we
have included the condition to say no
further first floor to be created um if
we look at the buildout of the barn
because this is a retrospective
application members we can see that
there was a barn erected on site
adjacent um and then subsequently
extended
and here it is from the 2020 view so we
have the existing barn and then we have
the additionality to the
rear and that is now walled and
complete um so the recommendation is as
it was originally which is to Grant
Subject
to
conditions um and the conditions are
laid out in the
amendment um before you the conditions
have been shared with the agent for the
application prior to today's meeting and
it's been indicated to officers that
those conditions are acceptable um I'll
turn over to members in case they have
any questions on the basis of the
submitted reports um before you move on
to your
debates thank thank you very much for
that happy to take questions for the
agent uh sorry for the um case officer
no okay
yeah sorry chair I was waiting for other
Come From First um condition number six
um on page 399 removal of permitted
development rights um how does that
secure us there not being another
building being built on this site
because obviously this is a
retrospective so
um you know there's already been
additional work
here is it just that we you know it
would be an Enforcement issue or is that
a strong enough condition thank you
chair
effectively it would be an enforcement
requirement
um the the the condition as requested
comes from the parish council and they
have concerns about um the level of hgv
traffic coming forward um from the site
now that's addressed within the report
um a present hgvs are used to take crop
off site dry it and then return it to
site whereas the provision of a drying
barn on site would mean that those hgvs
no longer need to go out through strap
book they're all contained within with
within the site um so the the condition
there members is just to um give Comfort
to the parish council that the barn
won't find itself in a more um active
commercial use under Class E um nor will
it find itself in a storage and
warehouseing use under class ba
additional development on the site will
be subject to planning control if it
requires it um there are of course
permitted development rights in place
for agricultural Holdings um but any new
application or any new development would
need to come forward for an application
thank
you any other questions yes councelor
field just about condition two um the
noise shall not exceed 35
DB l a equivalent um does that not need
some sort of averaging time associated
with it so that uh otherwise I could
measure it over 24 hours and run the
barn for 3 hours during the day and the
over average would be rather low so does
that require something else and I'm not
absolutely sure I understand the not
withstanding the existing ad plant and
heat exchanger are you saying the noise
from the drying Barn shall not exceed 35
DBS or the whole lot running together
shall not exceed 35 DBS which is seems
to be what the first paragraph of your
condition requires
so in terms of the the first part of the
condition that is as recommended by our
environmental health officers um and yes
so that first part of the condition is
to make sure we understand what the
total noise level from the anop digestor
there is a heat exchanger as part of the
ground Source heater array to the North
and the drying bar are together the
second part of the condition then states
that the ad plant on its own should not
exceed 35 DBS beyond the the
requirements
um if members want to discuss the
precise wording of the condition to see
if they want to impose a time
restriction in there that's a matter for
debate but in the view of officers and
your environmental health Team it's
considered that the wording of the
condition is sufficient for the purposes
that it's required to uh Monitor and
maintain thank you I'm not quite clear
then why we're doing the uh the first
paragraph you going away and monitoring
it and knowing what it is is all very
well well if you do something about it
but seem to imply that we do some
measurements and then somewhere else we
we make a um a firm requirement and
noise levels but not quite clear why
you're doing paragraph the first
paragraph if if members wanted in debate
that condition could be removed that's
within your gift to impose or not I mean
clearly my uh knowledge is somewhat out
of date I it's a bit difficult to debate
the exact wording in this meeting but I
would have thought you needed some sort
of average in time figure I'd be quite
happy if that was added I said I would
have thought there it needs some um time
measurement you know that you measure a
noise over a specific time and I'd be
quite happy for that to be added in I
can't
really debate it at this Point okay
Council maner uh thank you chair c can I
just query um condition three about the
lighting because the words minimum
necessary for the purposes of security
uh might be a bit subjective um and um I
wasn't at the um committee on the 15th
of September so I'm not particularly
familiar with this case but um I presume
this is a pretty rural location and you
don't really want lights on 24 hours
there so um I it is that condition are
we are we actually looking for some sort
of smart light lighting um provision
where it only comes on when when it
detects people there or whatever uh I
mean and is that wording strong enough
to to get us to to have a very minimal
lighting provision out in the
countryside I think that is the
intention of the of the condition um
it's not that we should be having
security lights running 24 hours a day
um although obviously given its
agricultural use you probably will have
vehicles accessing and leaving the site
24 hours a day and there probably is a
cons security concern 24 hours a day
given the nature of rural crime um in
terms of the condition again if members
wish to see that and see that amended
such that we have
um you know lighting be motion activated
outside of outside of certain hours um
then I think I think that would be
completely reasonable and is members are
open to consider that during their
debates thank you yeah Council M yeah
could we could we just include in the in
the lighting the usual biodiversity
considerations I suggest when we get to
debate questions Oh I thought question
yeah
whenever in I mean in response to that
we do have ecology requirements for that
sort of um sorry in in terms in terms of
um ecology requirements for that sort of
um lighting condition we do have those
set out by Play services fairly
regularly so I'm sure we could include
those within that condition and if
members wanted that to be a scheme to be
agreed we could deal with with it that
way or we could just outline what
requirements there are for um
biodiversity and making sure we're not
allowing certain species of bats to out
compete others and that sort of thing
thank you okay yes Council fur do you
want to come
back I've just been given a copy of page
422 of the document which is um from
suffer candy Council talking about about
noise and it
says uh control noise from crop dry
which sets a simple limit of 35 DB l a
equivalent without stating a measurement
period so as to be
unenforceable returns to what I was
saying
previously yeah that's well spotted on
the bottom of page
422 it does so it says that without
that measurement period it's
unenforceable so we need to think about
that in the conditions I think when we
come to it okay um depending on the
route we go okay members any other
questions we'll move on okay so we'll
now move on to public speakers
um the first up is the parish council we
have odal vladen welcome you have three
minutes please
thank you for your time today the parish
council is grateful to the officer for
making clear the conditions for this
retrospective application and fully
support these the parish council would
urge councilors to support the officer
recommendations which ensure that at
least some of the conditions previously
agreed by counselors for a large barn on
the same site are preserved and not
circumvented by simply building out a
granted smaller Barn than extending it
there are no reasons for these
recommended conditions to be varied
other than complying with suffet County
council's request for deciel monitoring
partly given that the application for
the smaller bar states that this this
drawing bar will mean there is no need
to take crops to and from an off-site
drwing facility and therefore the
conditions are reasonable and Justified
thank you thank you very much do you
have any questions to for the parish
council no okay thank thank you uh we
have no objector and no supporter today
uh but we have the agent Steve
Bainbridge and again over to you um and
you have three minutes we'll have to do
it electronically because that hasn't
run
through thank you good afternoon chair
and councelors my name is Steven
Bainbridge I'm a planning consultant and
a chartered member of the rural town
planning Institute I've been working on
the planning matters on this site since
the 2015 Planning Commission for the ad
partant next door I appeared before the
previous committee on this matter in
September having traveled up from Dorset
in the absence of the case officer in
order to assist the planning manager and
the committee on the form and function
of the proposed planning conditions uh a
gesture unfairly represented in your
report I have again reviewed the
officers report before you and again
agree with the principal recommendation
that's along with all the other planning
applications at Barley Brig Farm it' be
approved uh however as I've explained to
the case officer in my humble opinion uh
problems remain with the suggested
planning conditions however these are
not problems that will inhibit the
applicant and therefore in order to get
this planning application over the line
I leave it to this committee to judge
their acceptability in short I
Surrender however as always if you have
any questions I'm at your disposal one
of them might be wise condition two
prior to commissioning when this is a
regularization application thank
you okay thank you very much uh
questions at all for the agent do we
have
any no okay thank you uh Ward member is
Julie flatman um and we have something
that's coming I just need to get a copy
of thank
you okay so this is from councilor Julie
flatman uh chair and members apologies
for not attending in person
unfortunately I had a previous book
appointment I'd like to thank Danny for
the work he's put into this ongoing
application committee B have already
been privy to The Barley Big's
retrospective planning activities I'm
disappointed that not all the conditions
have been listed so clearly by the
parish council have been included
however if members are minded in
granting application I fully support the
officer's recommendation along with the
further suitable conditions that the
committee considered fit to
include okay so that's all the
information before us um obviously it's
come back to us again it's now up to us
to debate and discuss and come to a
conclusion Council pass good um thank
you very much Matthew so I think the
offic has done a good job here working
with the agent to come up with the
conditions I do know the site from the
point of view that I drive past it quite
often and it is a relatively remote site
actually obviously as we've seen it's
not anywhere near in the middle of the
village and I would like to move
approval of this with these conditions
and we also need to remember that this
is part of a an overall site so the
actual planning permission we're looking
at notwithstanding issues about lighting
commercial operations so on is very
important we get the balance right in
this and I think the officers have done
a very good job on this because there
are other issues for example grain
drying from the uh knowledge I have
which is a little historic now um it's a
much more efficient and more effective
operation and you don't have the noise
that you used to have years ago we could
probably hear it in the next Parish so I
would like to move approval with the
conditions that are there
um because I think we've had a good
discussion on this it was deferred I
think you proposed that previously
chairman and I seconded it and they've
come back with a set of conditions that
I think are workable and feasible they
do address most of the concerns that
people have I do think it will reduce
the amount of hgv traffic going through
streb which can be quite tricky at times
so I think overall with the work that's
been done it to marked improvement on
before therefore I am pleased to move
approval as set out in the papers thanks
can I just pick up how we're going to
deal with the noise the noise issue and
the time is John you want to come in
yeah just uh can I add to condition two
if I may just add two I'm going to make
them essentially as uh changes if I can
propose them to you uh firstly rather
than prior to uh we need to change could
we change that to within six within five
months instead because it is a
continuation of an existing application
so and and within those five months that
the monitor period shall be agreed in
writing with the local planning
Authority now the modering period could
be over an average of over eight hours
or it could be an hour and I think what
we need to do is discuss that with the
agent to agree a reasonable time and
involving our environmental health
officers as well so if I may add then
effectively in terms of condition to
just slightly altering it to say within
five months rather than the prior to and
uh also within that same five months
that the monitoring period for that
noise uh standard uh the length of over
which that would be measured is to be
agreed if I'm May chairman sorry John do
you mean five months from the date of
the planning permission it would be
yes well some might argue it's not but I
think it is in my
opinion
we have to be practical and that that's
why I'm asking you that it be reasonable
I think from what you say it seems to me
it' be reasonable so I'm happy to can I
just Pi
UPS uh so the lighting
one uh condition three being proposed
any external lighting associated with
the development shall be kept to a
minimum necessary for purposes of
security and S site safety and prevent
outward and upward and outward light
radiation if I'm going to be critical of
that condition essentially all that does
is stop lights looking up and looking
out of the site um it does no more than
that how long the lights go on for would
be up to the applicant um where they put
the lights would be up to them the
trouble is here we've also got to bear
in mind that we don't have any lighting
restriction that I know of Dan may be
able to help me on the existing rest of
the site so it' be a bit odd to be so
RVE over the lighting for this compared
to they could light up the rest of the
site you know like Christmas tree if I'm
being seasonal so
ultimately how reasonable is it to have
so much control over the
lighting suggest um that you talk to the
agent about this because the other issue
if you've got articulated lwes or other
things and Machinery moving around there
is a health and safety issue there so
you have to be reasonable about how
that's all put in not withstanding the
points you make I'm not disagreeing with
it but I would suggest suggest chairman
if I may through you that that is
something that does need to be discussed
you got the feeling of the committee
with the agent to come up to a practical
Solution that's reasonable again this
this condition is not asking for any
further
details so maybe can we add I think
that's what we need further details to
be agreed on external
lighting well in that case then I would
recommend that we essentially ditch this
condition and essentially say that all
external lighting requires planning
permission to be agreed with the local
planning Authority yeah fine
okay uh right so I don't have a seconder
yet uh councelor mat you're happy to
Second yeah second
the okay anyone else wish to speak
before we go to a vote no okay so uh can
we go to vote on that proposal
please thank you chair
members that vote is now in
progress
for
thank you members chair that's eight
votes SC that's unanimous okay thank you
very much and again I think another good
example of what we can do as a committee
and bringing things back so thank you to
the officers and the applicant for
working through that okay so um we've
got two more applications for us I'm
going to hand over the chair now for
this next item to councelor humph so I
have to step away um and we'll start
again in just a couple minutes just to
let people move
seats
ladies and gentlemen welcome back uh I
now assume the role of chairman for this
uh planning committee a we're now going
to look at DC 21's
0148 cherrygate Farm nor Road at mlan
and I'd like to ask the case officer
Daniel Cameron to introduce the
application to the
committee thank you chair um it's a
slightly unusual recommendation before
members um we have ongoing consultation
with eics and Subic water and with the
environment agency owing to the location
of the site being within a source
protection Zone and being within quite a
sensitive Source protection zone for
groundwater and I come to that aspect of
the application um in the presentation
when it's necessary but to go back to
the recommendation the recommendation
effectively is that we let that
conversation between the environment
agency and essics and suff water play
out and it's only on the removal of
their holding objections that permission
would be granted now the reason officers
have come before you with that
recommendation is that looking at the
other material
considerations we don't appear to have
anything that would also speak to an
objection that cannot be adequately
mitigated by conditions
um
we're on the western side of the a140
and the site here previously had uh
planning permission and it was used for
uh the production of ducks um for food
and for also um production of duck eggs
um that use has dwindled um and is now
no longer um operating from
site this application seeks the change
of use of the site um from an
agricultural use to B2 General
industrial use and the general
industrial use they want to undertake is
the production of structurally insulated
panels um used in construction of
modular housing um at present um the
applicant company has 22 employees
they'd be looking to expand another 18
jobs being created on the site um
following the change of use and the
change of use would also allow them to
rationalize their other sites such that
they could relocate their um production
and their um site onto one location
close to the a140 which is a primary hgv
distributor route within the county it's
about 10 kmet north of the A14 which is
the other primary hgv distributor route
in terms of uh the
access oh sorry let's go to constraints
first members we've got a few grade two
listed buildings one I don't know if you
can quite see it but I'll highlight it
for you one to the
Northwest one directly to the North and
then one off to sort of the Northeast um
again as with the previous application
the scales involved between the
application site and these listed
buildings as such it's not considered to
have a material impact on their settings
moreover because we're dealing with
change of use and there's no external
appear change to the appearance of the
buildings the landscape and therefore
setting of those listed buildings is
unchanged site is accessed down a 200
plus
meter single width
track and you'll see from the red line
members that the buildings within the
site change use of these indicated
you'll see from the site photos a number
of them are in good repair a number of
them are in less good repair um and
additional Works within the site are
proposed to repair those buildings and
bring them back into use White Oak Farm
is the nearest residential neighbor they
are an ownership of the land around um
and adjacent to the
a140 and they use that for the rearing
of
horses
want I quickly come on to um issues
surrounding surface water if I go back
actually that might be slightly better
um so the reason for the holding
objection from the environment agency
and from S6 andic water is that the site
is located close to a source protection
Zone
um these offer protections for areas of
large potable ground water and with
regards to this application we are
within 50 m of the groundwater so
therefore we are in surface water
protection Zone
one that 50 m um distance roughly
translate to around um 50 days or less
from any sort of chemical spill before
it reaches and infiltrates the
groundwater um and the closer you are to
the surface water protection Zone the
greater the risk of spills
to
groundwater now the risk with regards to
the application is chemical spill
infiltration to
groundwater um and in their consultation
the environment agency notes that these
are subject to um engineering Solutions
in order to remedy and prevent
spill if I move back ahead building
three is the only building within the
site to be used for the storage and use
of chemical and the idea is
that delivery vehicles would access test
the building would unload and would then
leave the site the building itself has a
concrete base that is proposed to be
sealed and any accesses to the building
are proposed to be bunded such that any
chemical spill that occurred within the
building would be housed completely
within the building and that the risk of
infiltration to groundwater is
effectively mitigated um by this the
issue
currently to be resolved with the
environment agency is the issue of what
happens to deliveries from the point of
which they leave the a140 because the
environment agent has no jurisdiction
over the Hall of chemicals on the
highway Network travels down the access
and accesses building three so that is
the scope of the continued negotiations
between the applicant and the
environment agency and as well the
resolution is that we would let those
technical conversations play out
um between the parties best place to
ajudge
them
um you'll see from your comments members
that highways have no issue with the
proposed access or visibility spays onto
the
a140 um previously large vehicles and
agricultural Vehicles were accessing the
site when it was in its agricultural use
and in terms of vehicle movements it's
propos that somewhere between 15 and 20
uh staff vehicle movements be to and
from the site per day we probably have
four to five car van movements for
customer visits and
collections there'd be 1 to two hgv
movements per weeks for goods inwards
and we'd have one to two HGB movements
and up to seven van movements per weeks
for goods
outwards in terms of H of chemicals on
the public Highway that'll be undertaken
by a specialist Holier you need sort of
all those sort of special licenses
adapted vehicles um in order to be able
to undertake that sort of work
let's just check give you everything I
want
to if we move ahead now to images of the
site and you'll get an idea about how
close the
residential neighbor is to the site here
we are at the access to the site at the
end of the access road you'll note its
width and you'll note some of the
buildings within the site
this gray building here is building
three and that is the one proposed to be
utilized for the storage and use of
chemical this is the access back towards
the a140 you can see the mast in the
distance and that point there just at
the vanishing point just notes where the
a140 connects to the site um we have
garages here serving the adjacent
residential dwelling and at this point
we also have a driveway serving it
there's a small garden to the frontage
as you'll see from the layout Maps and
then behind that we have White
Oaks if we move now to Google image
searches um images of the a140 access
this is the view of the a140 Northbound
just beyond this yellow vehicle here
members we have the access to the
site and this is the access to the site
here we have a slight
slip before
accessing and then this is the view
southbound and we have the ACT access
point indicated
here as we move around the site we have
buildings one and two these are in a
general good state of repair and at the
south southern P point of the
site uh we then see the rear of
buildings one and two and we can also
see the rear of building three and the
hard standing
surrounding moving forward we have the
frontages of buildings one two three and
four in the
distance and then a better view of state
of building three with its uh motorized
door in terms of the rest of the site we
have um a large storage barn open-sided
and you'll also know we have some other
buildings which are more General State
of
disrepair um the application would be
seeing repair undertaken to these
buildings um such as sort of all the
ancillary um operations that are needed
sort of office space um to support the
building would be provided on site as
well if we come back to the access
view I think this one's good um we do
have comments from the parish council
and from the neighboring property with
regards to amenity um in your report
members you'll note that the applicants
are particularly Keen to address
conditions to serve um amenity concerns
um so we have proposed hours of office
work and we have um a schedule for
deliveries um so that we can limit those
to specific times so any use of the uh
access way you know you are aware of
when those large vehicles are coming
into and out of
sight um it's also noted with regards to
noise that noisy activities like The
Cutting of structurally insulated panels
would only occur during agreed
times and there's also a condition there
to ensure that any night working we
reduce the number of vehicle movements
to and from the site such that night
workers are prevented from parking on
the site and that use of a crew bus is
utilized for their access and egress
from the site um I'll pass on to
members
um for any questions arising from the
report and the information provided
before moving into your
debates so now we will go to questions
councilor Ean please
please thank you very much chair thank
you Daniel for your report um I've got
two sort of sets of questions as it were
on highways um when highways give a
response they just refer to hgvs that
they don't I'm assuming they don't have
any um particular response that they
have to make regarding hazardous vehicle
hgvs and if um what would happen if two
hgvs met on that access way um if you
could answer that please um and then
secondly um
you referred to engineering Solutions
with regards to potential contamination
but I thought ess6 and suffk water
implied there weren't um and could you
say why the in the in the conditions you
just referring to discussions with the
environment agency and not also with
essics and suff at water thank you very
much thank you
chair need to turn myself on so in terms
of the um highways comment um to their
mind hgvs would be the most disruptive
Vehicles using that access so that's
their that's their focus there um in
terms of um what should happen should
two hgvs meet um that is an existing um
issue that could erupt on the site given
its current agricultural use were it to
go back into that agricultural use the
previous permissions on that site don't
control vehicle movements to and from
the site um whereas the recommendation
before you do propose those sort of
conditions so that we can have better
control over that and we can know what
what happens at that point um at present
and on other sort of similar accesses
that we have along the a140 to um
similar sites there is normally an issue
whereby if one one hvv is looking to
leave the site another needs to queue on
the road um that is an existing issue
and it's not one that the highway
Authority have um noted as being
particularly objectionable at this point
now in terms terms of the a140 at that
point you have a fairly good level of
visibility and are able to
make slow and then allow the one hvv to
leave the site and the other to access
um so I think highways would assume that
that would continue with regards to um
bringing in of um product building
through wouldn't allow an hgv to access
it um so move a little product into the
site chemical product into the site
would be done by sort of a larger van um
that's already been adapted for that
purpose so it wouldn't be the case that
we'd have
hgvs um full of chemical arriving and
leaving the site the the sort of nature
of the um of the use is that you have
sort of Fairly regular deliveries of the
chemical and you're effectively topping
up your weekly or monthly use so you're
never bringing in sort of
a you know in terms of the amount of
chemical that we have noted in the
submission documents I think we have two
tons um of two chemicals and then about
400 lers of a cleaning solvent you'd
effectively be wanting to bring in an
amount and then bring in a secondary
amount and then once you have that
filled you'd be just looking to top up
so you wouldn't be looking to bring in
substantial levels of um chemical via
hgv to and from the site um the other um
the other point about engineering
Solutions um it's worth bringing up the
conversations have been ongoing with the
applicant and um the environment agency
and with regards to works of building 3
I think they are generally satisfied
however would like to see that
additional detail provided just so they
have full clarity over the entirety of
the of the site so the point where the
vehicle leaves the the a140 and then
proceeds to building
three um they're generally happy with
what's been done to building three and I
think they there is a need to just let
those conversations play out um if
members would prefer that the resolution
be amended to include eics and suff
water within that resolution I think
that's for members to Grant within their
debate um to my mind the environment
agency and the lead consult te with
regards to the groundwater protection um
eics and suff water manage that on their
behalf so if the environment agency is
satisfied with regards to The Spill and
risk mitigation then ethics and suff
water should also be satisfied in that
regard chair may I just come back um you
you mentioned um thank you very much for
your responses first um and you
mentioned something in the conditions
about the access way but I couldn't see
it about Vehicles meeting or not so if
you could just qualify that thank
you so in terms of um that condition it
would be the bullet point that states
limit to hours of delivery both to and
from the site so we are in control of a
schedule that's very clear these states
and times when deliveries are to come to
site and leave site I mean we can't
control um all vehicles to and from the
site customers will likely turn up as
and when and will'll have to allow for
that but the meeting of two cars um is
not going to be as detrimental as the
meeting of two HG and I would suggest
that that condition probably is worded
to make sure that we can control that
adequately CC maton
please thank you yeah the um the
planning history um mentions
agricultural workers dwelling etc etc is
that white oak or or is there some other
um potentially residential property
lurking
somewhere on the
site
no my assumption is that's quite o
That's since move that now doesn't have
the tie on it but I suspect that we can
bring that up when comments come forward
there's a shake of the head but I won't
put words in anyone's mouth at that
point second question yes please yeah
the I noticed that there obviously been
quite deto consideration of the
quantities and weights and so on and so
forth of the chemical coming in um I I
was wondering whether the quite minimal
County Council um page
465 um fairly minimal comment about
hdvs um was was based on
any any any further Evidence really I
mean I I looked at 40 employees and what
they're making
and the volume of material that's being
put taken in and taken out um is
actually quite substantial in order to
make a living for 40 people and um so I
did wonder about that and I think from
that I I look at the one or two hgv
movements uh outwards and and how big
are these seven seven Vans um you know
we've got to actually
know that the quantity of of material is
going to go out on that number of
vehicles help us with that slow you down
down John a lot of this is subjective um
if you'd like to answer the question on
the evidence please so we have we have
the conditions to control vehicle
movements to and from the site um in
terms of the Agricultural use of the
site if we were to move back in there we
don't have any conditions that control
that so we could be looking at something
that is
um requires a greater number of hgvs to
from the site we could be looking at
something quite intensive there's no um
there's no control there so we wouldn't
have you know we we could be looking at
a a large number of agricultural
vehicles and huvs accessing the site in
an agricultural use um those accesses
could be 24 hours a day um with this
application we have control over hours
of access and we can control noise and
amenity impacts which we we might not
necessarily have control over given the
age of the Agricultural um planning
permission on the
site yeah come back on on debate and
also questions for the agent councelor
Passmore please um thanks Barry yeah
just a a technical Point here we are
looking here at giving or deciding
whether to give change of permission to
be to use yet it's a specific use for um
manufacturing insulated p panels what
I'm trying to get at here is if you are
we actually looking at B2 or
specifically just for insulated panels
cuz they're in my mind there might be a
difference because there are plenty of
other B2 uses if you see what I mean
thank you so I think with regards to the
change of use it is just to a general B2
use if members wanted to see a
restriction there we could impose
condition to say that the b2u shall only
be for the construction manufacturer and
other
you know office based tasks related to
production of structurally insulated
panels members might also want to
consider whether or not the planning
permission on the site might be better
suited to um a personal POS permission
for supers siips themselves so that you
aren't then um you aren't then looking
at another B2 user coming onto the site
um and increasing vehicle movements to
and from the site if that is something
that members would like to open up in
debate the the point I'm making in
planning terms um a use class is a use
class and a more um a more common
um instance is in the High Street if you
have a you know a small news agent and
that is then to change use to um say you
know an estate agent or something that
is um less useful to the current
occupants of the High Street
nevertheless within the Realms of a
classy commercial use um there isn't a
planning reason to restrict that
um where we are with the B2 use on site
um we have a condition to state that we
wouldn't want to see that move to a B8
storage and warehousing use because that
would likely increase the number of hgvs
coming into the site and leaving the
site um what I think um members might
want to consider in debate is whether or
not they are content with the general B2
use on the site or whether they would
like to condition that that B2 use be
for the construction and manufacturer
and sale of structurally insulated
panels or whether they would like to
restrict that use further and say the
only user of the site we want to see is
supers
siips reason perly reasonable to
designate it just for this specific use
as opposed to B2 in
general um I'll just get some legal
advice and some area planning officer
advice on that
please
I was having this conversation with uh
the case officer actually just before um
and there's a couple of aspects that
we've got some vacant buildings on this
site as well but the application covers
the entire
site so the discussion
was what is the planning harm of
potential
intensification that could result and
you got vac buildings there that
essentially could be an
expansion um and of course if suddenly
traffic um for a different user at a
different type of B2
use meant that the traffic levels would
be unexpectedly high or there would be
other
harm where could we be reasonable to
control that in this particular bespoke
instance given the residential property
uh adjacent to the site and given the
access arrangements as well because they
are restricted to a certain degree um so
it is it is not
normally well it's not often done that
we personalize a
permission um but that's not to say it
can't be done and it hasn't been done it
has been done it is a valid planning
thing to
do um and but the advice we have is if
you're going to do it you really have to
be very clear in your justification of
why you are personalizing it to such an
extent now in this instance I would
suggest that it possibly is an
opportunity to personalize it because
you have full information about the
operations of this particular user on
this particular site and a different
user and its different operation of B2
could be quite detrimental potentially
to the occupier adjacent to the site and
the particular um in intensification of
the access and so on so my advice would
be that you could if you wish to
consider personalizing it to Super slips
limited only that is a valid
consideration in your debate I would add
to that you may will well also wish to
add that the vacant buildings are shown
on the plan are to be for storage only
in assoc negotiation with that
business so they are not subdivided off
later on thank you and Ian anything else
to add yeah can I um if I may with with
personal plan permissions I mean how I
defer to John on on his greater and
longer local knowledge of this part of
suffk I mean have they been used for
commercial premises in mid suffk before
or
commonly more commonly they are more
residential
based if you have that was my point if
you have a permission that's a
permission with a condition a personal
permission that says this Caravan on the
back field residential Caravan will only
stay there as long as Jane John and Jane
Smith or one or other of them is there
that's easy to understand and enforce so
with a company obviously companies can
be reformed and restructured though
that's probably the applicant's problem
rather than ours if we were to say supit
limited then that company would have to
be the one in occupation under the
condition wouldn't it I suppose so I go
back to Dan's point which was was you
know there are levels at this we've said
we were saying
B2 the next level up is well actually
we're going to restricted to the actual
operational activity which is in this
case is the insulation panels
manufacturer the SEC the kind of extreme
level is to then personalize it and that
is why members need to be clear in their
justification of why they're taking it
to that extent but it is available but
like you said it's uncommon L
done thank you hopefully that's provided
you with enough answers to form debate
later which we obviously going to come
back to this so thank you uh we're going
to councelor field then councelor Manel
councelor
mayor thank you couple of points um
first of all noise levels you you've got
a condition that that talks about 5 DBS
above
background uh would be interesting to
know as there's a number of other insul
noise insulation conditions in there as
well um it would be interesting to know
what background you at uh peak time on E
a140 or at the dead of night or or
whatever um secondly there's no
requirement on sort of odors from the
site and I thought that TDI was quite a
considerable problem in that area there
certainly are comments in the text about
it uh tendency to
um sensitize people to asthma and what
have you so it's not a nice chemical the
way I read the documents and uh one
wonders are there odor
issues uh the third question really is
been covered to an extent before that
you don't seem to have or you're not
considering the water company as a prime
uh consultant really um and yet the the
the concern that they have and the
concern the environment agency have
about uh two tons of uh quite um
concerning materials being stored on so
it seems within 50 MERS did you say a
ground W to extraction site
um is is quite apparent so I'm really
wondering why we are choosing to move
ahead with this application before we
have final sign off from uh so
particularly the water company who
clearly are concerned that should there
be an accident here they will finish up
unable to
supply save that for debate and if you'd
answer the questions please yeah no so
um consultation with environmental
health hasn't raise concern over um odor
issues um if members were minded to we
could certainly look into that um
alongside the um opportunity we're
giving for the EA and um for if members
want to as well essics and suff water to
come back and be satisfied with regards
to um groundwater protection and and
spill
risk so um that is within members grasp
to uh consider in their debate whether
or not they wish to amend the resolution
in front of them to include essics and
suff water as well as the environment
agency um and also to seek additional
comments from environmental health prior
to Grant on odor um that would be
entirely reasonable within the remit of
planning committee to determine within
their
debate thank you thank you councilor
Manel please uh thank you I I I think
all this conversation is actually making
me more confused um the description of
the development is change of use of land
and buildings from poultry unit to
structural insulated panel
manufacturer and then we have that the
total Site Area is 3.1 hect a and the
internal floor space which we're
changing uh trying to determine whether
we want to change the use is
6,677 square meters so we're now talking
about maybe putting restriction on the
use so if only if only 6.7 6,700 square
meters or thereabouts is being change of
use the rest of the site area could
presumably still be used as a poultry
unit because that's what it is already
so
are those buildings that are not being
used for the uh manufacturer of ulated
panels um they're not being change of
views they're still agricultural are
they I I'm a bit confused just one on
that transl to questions because we
talked about what we're debating we're
not debating anything at the moment or
or possible conditions that's debate so
we'll stick with
questions um Mr P G first please if I
may sorry Dan um ultimately the red line
is the change of use so the entire site
is the proposal for change of use um
we're not looking to retain anything in
terms of poultry use in the technicality
of what this is because of course the
moment you walk around the site you're
being breach you know you're effectively
operating two uses and you there
wouldn't be the overlap possible there
um this the red line specifically
defines the whole area and that is what
is all to be manufacturing of and and
part and would be um essentially the B2
yes the description of development says
manufacturing of insulation unit
but unless you to put a restriction on
that that could change into any B2
thereafter so that's why we've got a
condition to that effect does that help
well that doesn't quite answer my
question because my question was really
does the
6,677 square meters a floor space which
is changing use is that cover all of the
buildings on the site or is that only
some of the buildings because it's just
that we're you're you're now saying it's
the change of use of the land the whole
3.1 hectares is being changed from
agricultural to B2 yes so that would
include both buildings and surrounding
area outside of the buildings so so my
question is really does the 6,677 square
meters cover all the buildings on that
site does it Dan so if we niit back to
the presentation in the red line area I
think that would clear up a lot of the
issue so this is the red line area this
is the L which would change use and
these are the buildings within that land
which will provide that
6,677 square meters so there would be an
area around the buildings for sort of
movement of um Goods throughout the site
would be chemicals was completely
restricted to um building
three so if we come back it's only that
hatched area that would change used to
be to and it's those buildings Within in
that red line area that would change use
all
of thank you uh councelor mayor
please question is it possible to put a
condition in to restrict hgv movements
to the site two reasons firstly not all
the buildings are being used at the
moment and if this facility is
successful it could expand dramatically
that's happened to a company on in my
own Ward which would then drive up the
number of HG Vehicles above what we're
being told today and secondly if we were
able to limit hgv Vehicles it to my mind
would remove the need to be more
specific about the site it could remain
B2 because we have control over Vehicles
we have control over noise so if more
businesses were able to operate within
that then that wouldn't be a
concern I think officers would probably
need a little bit of time to think about
the precise wording of a condition to
deal with that um conditions are are
utilized to to monitor hvv trips into
and out of a site now my understanding
is that the highway Authority Define a
trip as either a vehicle movement into
or a vehicle movement out of so if you
have something going into a site being
filled and then leaving that's two trips
um we probably need to have a think
about a maximum number of hgv movements
to and from the site that would be
acceptable and we probably need to think
about what period of time um we would
want to see um that number
adhere to so you know do we do we want
to say a certain number of vehicle
movements per year which I think is a
standard and I think there is then a
question about um how are those recorded
and measured because it's possibly
better to have it recorded um on site
such that at any point our Enforcement
Officers could ask to see you know a log
of vehicle movements HV movements to and
from the site and then have something
with which that they can enforce um the
difficulty comes if if there is a
perception that the applicant might
somehow want to fiddle those numbers and
not accurately record them because
ultimately the issue then becomes
Enforcement Officers need to be present
on the site 24 hours a day to ensure
that we don't have more hdvs coming in
and leaving the site than is being
recorded it's it's not Beyond it's not
beyond our powers to do so but I think
we just need to be careful over wording
thank you thank you uh Council Stringer
please thank you chair sorry sorry
there's so many questions but it's sort
of one of those type of applications I
think can
we can I just have a bit more clarity
about what is meant when is redundant
redundant I think is my question uh
because as councelor Manel said the
whole of the site has been requested to
move into B2 use but which technically
would mean everything on that site would
be able to be used for that purpose but
we have an indicative plan that the
County Council has responded to showing
most of the buildings not being used so
is it possible then to condition that
those buildings remain redundant or can
we get an assessment
of so if we approve what's in the papers
today are they able to then bring those
buildings into use without another
planning application and another
response from the highways Department
so I I think probably the comment goes
back to the the condition raised by um
Mr pman G I think if we were looking to
say
um that you know we we could have a
condition that states very clearly you
know buildings one two three Etc are
moving into the B2 use buildings noted
on on submitted plan to remain redundant
shall be held so or shall be um utilized
for no other purpose other than storage
um we then have a condition that we can
control and should suip want to change
um that arrangement we could then look
at a variation of condition with them to
submit a new plan and if we needed to
get more comments from the highway
authority over vehicle
movements can I come back yeah a
building used for storage is not
redundant
and it UPS the capacity of a factory
being able to store more and guess what
storage comes in on an hgv normally or a
vehicle of some description that's why I
still can't believe it was originally
came in in March and we now in December
still can't you have your moment
questions thank you are there any other
questions okay in that case sorry my
question was are we going to answer that
okay are they redundant or are they not
if we approve this application Mr P G
please at the moment as it stand with
the conditions currently recommended by
officers um they could be used for B2
use that's the proposal in front of us
um just a word of warning if we're going
to get into trying to condition them to
have no use that is a legal nightmare I
would have to have some advice over and
I'm thank you
okay uh if there are no further
questions uh we have no public speakers
no one from the parish council but we do
have an objector which is Mr Kevin blch
uh Mr blch you have three minutes from
the time you start thank
you thank you chair uh we are the owners
of White Oak Farm a home and deine
property most directly affected in terms
of Highways and residential amenity our
property surrounds Cher gate farm on the
east and south sides but we share the
driveway which passes next to our Garden
within a few meters of our Bungalow the
existing permission is for egg laying
which for the past 20 years required
only three employees on a single day
shift the duck sh sheds were cleaned
every six months Cherry Gate Farm is
Circ Seven Acres with eight existing
large btry sheds and a Dutch Barn whilst
the application is for change of use
industrial for the whole site the
supporting noise and traffic
documentation submitted with the
application relates to use by the
applicant only and is also based upon
use of only three of the nine buildings
should the other buildings be used the
noise and traffic documentation will be
invalid the application form at section
19 applies for a day shift Monday to
Friday only the noise assessment and
traffic report discuss 24-hour working 7
days per week utilizing three
shifts a small bellmouth entrance of the
a140 leads into the single Lane 205 M
long driveway V vehicles cannot pass in
both
directions the applicant suggest
currently having 40 employees on the
site 13 times more than your previous
use the applicant uses large Open Back
Vans with large trailers to move his
materials in and out of the s it some
deliveries are by articulated hgv Lorry
highways did not object on the premise
of little increase in vehicles and no
increase in
hgvs should Vehicles be trying to leave
the property when a vehicle enters the
driveway they will either have to
attempt a dangerous reverse down the
driveway which will be difficult in the
unlit driveway or the vehicle entering
will have to either stop or reverse back
onto the
a140 crash map shows two fatal accidents
two serious accidents and numerous other
accidents in the few hundred yards
either side of the driveway in the past
years the highways Authority raised no
objection on the basis that vehicle
movements would not be increased to a
level that proves severe harm but
traffic will increase dramatically and
stationary Vehicles will be on 140 we
lead horses which are spooked very
easily across the drive at least twice a
day to access pcts and Stables unless
traffic is controlled we anticipate a
serious accident the environment agency
and Water Authority have not removed
their objections in
conclusion if permission is granted we
think it should contain conditions that
the site is restricted to the sole use
of the applicant for the manufacturer of
his panels it's limited to the limits to
the hours of production and other use of
the site noise limits should be imposed
the Water Authority concerns should be
addressed as it as well as the
environment agency and measures should
be implemented for the safety of the
horses thank you thank you are there any
questions please for Mr
blch okay I've got one question the um
traffic um crash map that the serious
and the Fatal injuries that relate to
one incident or
many a number of incidents thank you
there are no supporters present
therefore we'll now move to the uh agent
uh Mr James plat
please good afternoon members firstly
thank you for the opportunity today to
speak in support of the application sups
is a well established and successful
local business currently operating from
a premises at newborn a location to the
east of ipswitch and notably outside of
mids District sups provide provide sales
design production and manufactur
structural insulated panels commonly
known as sips a building system that is
extremely strong energy efficient and
cost effective notably the panels use
significantly less energy during the
manufacturing process compared to
traditional construction methods and
have lower embodied energy than
traditional materials such as steel
concrete and masonry soup sips has grown
rapidly since 2011 cating for customers
across the UK and Beyond this growth of
the business has given rise to job
creation locally with 22 members of
Staff currently employed the growth of
the business has however brought with it
logistical problems and the current
premises does not ultimately represent a
long-term viable solution for the
business hence the proposal you see
before you
today the proposal site is well situated
uh suited to the demands of the business
enabling the ReUse of existing buildings
to meet operational need while
strategically well placed to provide
direct access to the a140 and in regard
to the site's connectivity to the
Strategic Highway Network the
sustainable location means that
emissions can be reduced and impacts on
the rural Highway Network minimized
furthermore the location remains
accessible to employees and it's
environmentally and operationally
advantageous to site office manufacturer
and distribution uses
together the proposal site meets both
the current and new requirements of the
business anticipate anticipated generate
a further 18 jobs which will account for
new drivers manufacturing operatives and
office staff in order to progress the
application the applicant has gone to
Great Lengths to provide various
technical reports and supporting
information this has included continued
discussion with the environment agency
and the incorporation of measures to
effectively drisk the storage and use of
chemicals on the site these measure
measures include the limitation of
storage and use of chemicals to a single
building within the site the cealing of
this building at a raised threshold to
ensure spill containment and delivery of
chemicals directly within the building
itself
accordingly the risk of groundw is
considered to be suitably mitigated to
conclude a grant of Planning Commission
in this case would secure the expansion
of existing successful business looking
to invest in the district the permission
would secure the long-term use and
viability of what is ultimately a
redundant site in a strategically pref
preferred location on the a140 corridor
we consider the proposal Define in
principal favor with the development
plan and it Accords with it when viewed
as a whole furthermore the development
would comply with the policies of the
mppf taken as a
for these reasons we respectfully ask
for your support of The Proposal thank
you again for the opportunity to
speak thank you members are there any
questions for Mr plat councelor eburn
followed by counselor Matson
please thank you very much chair thank
you for that um I I'm sure I heard the
um planning officer say that the area
around the access road was in the your
client's ownership um had you considered
um and and he referred to a very slight
slip as in slip we of the a140 have you
considered um or did you consider within
this application um taking more Landing
to make sure that there was a bigger um
area so that um Vehicles could pull off
the a140 and to mitigate the meeting of
two vehicles on the access road thank
you very
much okay thank you um so I think the
starting point obviously with a
formulation of the sort development
proposal um is to gay sort relevant
consultant so um we've obviously had an
input of a uh a transport engineer um
who reviews obviously the visibility
achievable on site so I think within our
transport statement it's quoted Beyond
215 mters um so also with speed surveys
that was obviously Quantified what would
be realistically a required visibility
playay so I think the starting point is
to understand where the axis is
obviously safe to facilitate the
movements that are going to be generated
so given the fact that the visibility is
is considered be suitable um there
wasn't any need in our eyes obviously to
seek improvements to that access um and
we think that's obviously cated but
covered off within the high authorities
response uh Dan if you like to come in
and assist please that might be
apologies if I've created any confusion
there um so the redline application site
doesn't include the land either side of
the access the land either side of the
access is owned by White Oaks so any any
Improvement to the slip or to widening
of the road we need to be done with
their
agreement thank you counc maton please
yes thank you yeah I I um I was looking
at the the you know the idea that that
you're going to employ 40 people
presumably fulltime and um the the
payment the payroll alone will be 20,000
a week or something um plus um on costs
to that and um so you the business has
got to generate that amount of of you
know valid alue added value on top of
the materials themselves and I mean how
many houses presumably you're going to
mainly build houses with these
units count M let's just stick to the
subject matter which is this Planos
absolutely with the matter I'm Sor
question the question is quite clear is
is is about you know what are the the
volumes how many houses will you need to
to produce of per week and deliver um
and and the sub the other question
associated with that is these bands that
are mentioned um I mean how how big are
they actually are they small hgvs almost
or or are they transits
or somewhere between yeah I I'll just
try and get us back on track so the
amount of production that they produce
that's not we're discussing we're
discussing the planning application I'm
happy with the question on the on the
vehicle size because that is
relevant it's my point and that's the
one I'm sticking to uh answer the
question please on the vehicle
so I think within the um within the
transport statement sorry I'm just
pulling that up at the moment um I think
there was a sort of breakdown of
individual Vehicles so I think obviously
the classification of van I I believe
has a kind of specific um or it's
classified based on the wheel base so
when when they're referenced as Vans you
know they're effectively classified as
such and then hgvs are are a separate
type of vehicle um so sorry I'm just
trying to pull up my the transport
statement um but with within that
document they are clearly set out in
terms of the separate movements and the
classification of vehicles so I suppose
in answer your question
um a van obviously is a van by
definition um in terms of its
classification a vehicle and HTV is a
separate type of um type of
vehicle thank you any other questions
please yes uh I'll go for councelor
field followed by by you councelor
Stringer thank
you thank you um
you have heard from the questioning I
was somewhat concerned about noise and
odors do you have any issues that type
with your existing site or am I totally
wrong um so in terms of the the position
of the existing site I know it's um
closer to kind of neighboring occupiers
and as far as I'm aware is obviously the
the um applicant hasn't been the subject
to complaint in terms of oders I'd also
add that in terms of the management
obviously and use of this chemical um
it's stored in sealed IBC so effectively
it's not um you know exposed to the air
um so in terms of generating odors given
it's in a sealed container I expect
obviously it wouldn't generate
significant odors to be of
concern so you don't mix the chemicals
to generate a foam or anything like
that they're always sealed
somewhere um so in terms of the
chemicals obviously the process
effectively some of the chemical is
taken from the stored ibcs and then used
to obviously mix um and create a foam um
you know in terms of odors I could the
the applicant who is in attendance today
could give give an Insight in terms of
the odors but I'm not aware of that
being of any concern with the current
use of the site um and in terms of
quantities obviously the information the
application we're talking about the the
storage really and the maximum Quantum
of chemical um obviously that is
effectively taken from the ibcs in in
quantities that then allow to be used
you know at that moment in time so again
we're not talking about significant
quantities of of chemical being sort of
um exposed to the air and then obviously
then you know particulates sort of
obviously entering into the air and then
being
transmitted okay uh councelor Stringer
please yeah thank you chair
um I have a small amount of experience
in SS panels I live in a house made from
them um so just just to be clear about
the process and deliveries sips panels
are normally made out of what I call
sticks bits of Timber that make the
frame and then there's a panel that goes
on them and then a foam type insulation
injected into the void is that correct
no someone shaking their head okay uh
perhaps that can be clarified how these
panels yeah sorry yeah please do yeah I
think it'd be useful the app can is here
could probably talk about that proc you
answer that specific question
please that is a
yeah yeah if you just come forward to
the
microphone there's one this should be
just one on your left hand side you
could probably
use my apologies this is a sip or be a
small sample of it they come in an 8
before sheet they are actually a
polyurethane foam injected the system is
sealed the chemical SLE from the IBC in
a sealed system to the mixing head in a
sealed system injected into a sealed
mold it has to retain 65 tons of
pressure when it expands so the system
has to be sealed otherwise this phone
will go
everywhere so there was no Timber around
the panel that's the old timber frame
systems where they used to make a timber
frame and then inject the foam
specifically to do the insulation aspect
side of things thank you string yeah
yeah that's very helpful so how does how
is the foam prevented from spilling out
from the 8 before
sheet by a retention system a mold
system that retains it and the sheets of
OSB board that you're holding how are
they how do they come to sight they come
to site on a HTV they're the only htvs
we
need yeah coming in because they are
delivered with 18 packs at a time the
chemicals are delivered on a small
either a 7 and a half ton maximum is a
10 ton and they come in ibcs which is
only 1,000 lers at a time the the other
chemical the the dangerous one as
everybody calls it comes in 800 liters
so we only store on buns which is sealed
containers which we are operating in IP
switch at the moment down on the docks
there is no odors because the chemical
becomes a solid Mass from the
transportation from the I BC into the
mold there's no actual air and as soon
as the two chemicals are mixed within
the mold it comes out looking like that
it doesn't smell thank you allow that to
continue because it's actually very
useful and there's one other point one
final question yeah yeah and once the
panels made they leave on a van and
trailer correct correct how many van and
trailers a week we have we have we run
L5 transits the bulk of them run just as
an L5 Transit on its own it's only on
exceptional circumstances bearing in
mind that through vosa law we can't
operate more than 100 miles from the
depot with the trailer right so the
trailers are there to be used if we can
to obviously cut down doing two
deliveries instead of one but there is a
restriction of 100 miles so if for
example I was delivering to Cornwall it
would go out on an L5 Transit van thank
you and we only operate eight currently
thank you that that's fine thank you
you're going to get your moment Council
s sorry chair but I did ask how many I
didn't want to know what they were made
from how many a week go out fine because
if there's eight of them they could be
going out eight times a day each it was
very informative thank you thank you for
asking the question I'm sure it helped
everybody I'd like to uh thank uh Mr BL
and also Mr Platt uh and obviously the
owner for your contribution to the
meeting it's it's definitely appreciated
thank you uh let's move on to council
string award
member thank you chair uh yeah when I
first saw uh this application come I I
thought some of my birthdays will come
at once uh a a sustain structurally
insulated panel manufacturer is a really
good thing to have uh because they will
form an awful lot of part of the future
of of construction there's several ways
of construction constructing the panels
as we've gone through today um some of
them use more toxic chemicals than
others to to formulate the panels uh etc
etc uh there are two huge Mains of
concern though that I've had as this
application's gone through the process
so it starts with Jubilation that we've
got an interesting uh Factory coming uh
which which could could bring about
employment and sustainable uh structure
engineered panels insulated panels the
the main issue I have a problem with or
the community also has a problem with is
how the site sits it's got either side
of a quite a narrow track uh a land
ownership that's domestic and it has
horses as well and the horses cross that
track fairly regularly as well so that
that's a slight concern anyway with
lorries and you know but you we couldn't
control it under the agricultural
commission either so you know it is one
of those so that's a bit of a concern
the huge concern I have is the response
from the highways officer and this is
not for the first
time her suggesting that the traffic
movements of a factory like this would
be identical to those of a duck egg
rearing Farm I think is beyond
fantasy um structurally engineered
panels by their design are a lot bigger
than duck egg and they're also a lot
bigger than a duck egg in
value uh so you had three employees
employees on site on site making duck
eggs with the enhanced value in the duck
egg that was then going into something
to be delivered which is relatively
small the the concern here is you have a
single track in and out of this site
with no right turn filter off the a140
and no leftand filter off the
a140 if you have you should be going up
this track at about 10 mil hour you
should be less than 15 because you're
near horses that will take you 1 minute
52 seconds to get up this track so if
someone's coming to turn left with a
delivery into site
and there is something coming the other
way they may have to sit with their
backside out onto the a140 for almost 2
minutes before that vehicle
leaves it and gets out of the way uh
equally one turning right could be the
same thing if they're turning right and
the other one's tur right they might not
be able to get out because depending on
where that truck is I'm disappointed the
County Council has not forecast that
eventuality the other issue is the
proximity of this extraction for
Waterhead uh that is quite vital we have
to be absolutely assured that no
chemical will spill from here or enough
dust from cutting any panels will get
anywhere near this because if it gets
anywhere near this contamination that
will be of districtwide significance if
we contaminate that water supply so like
I say coming from a position of this
could be a really good thing I'm also
very concerned that the amount of
buildings that are flagged as redundant
on
here that could be brought into play
without any recourse to anyone in the
system every consulty has responded to
this amount of buildings being in
use if the rest of the buildings were
brought back into use by approval as as
it stands today we could end up with an
awful lot more traffic movements than
anyone's assessed here even given the
response to the assessment
so my position would be as District
counselor here understand the need for
the manufacturing process agree that's a
good thing but I would be really
reluctant if I was a Committee Member to
approve this application unless I was
fully assured that there is going to be
no chemical leakage from here and you've
got that in writing and that you are
completely assured that this operation
can flourish as I wish it
will on two deliveries a week thank you
chair thank you councelor Stringer
members any questions for the W
member okay thank you in that case uh
we're going to open for debate who's
going to
start councelor field
please yes I find
as M said um it's good to see a an
industry that's prospering and one
that's
um producing the sort of products we
wish to see and employment is always
good so so there are some really
positives
here but I find uh as I read through the
papers the Cs from the environment
agency and from the water company really
concerning um the environment AG it says
it is imperative that none of these
substances are allowed to reach the
groundwater in the aquiares at depth and
and that's just one sentence picked out
of
a two and a half page document uh which
is
more concerning than than any I've seen
I think in my years as a council here
the same sort of thing goes with Essex
and sou Walter who who we understood not
whose views don't seem to have been
taken into account so far they
subsidiary to the environment
agency and you know again a couple of
pages I won't try and pick a sentence or
two that they all show a great deal of
concern um
with possible contamination of the
supply of water to quite a lot of human
beings in the
area now if those two agencies had
completely signed off as being happy
with with the precautions taken bearing
in mind that you know none of us want to
see problems we all invent things to
prevent accidents to control substances
of this nature but history is that uh
we're not usually totally
successful so I find the fact those two
agencies have not signed off really
concerning um and there is also a
highway issue
as has been mentioned uh as far as I'm
aware accidents on the a140 are almost
always related DET turnings to accid to
entrances and exits from the road it's
not just um bad driving on the actual
road so so there is an issue there I I
tend to feel that that one could be
could be solved uh perhaps in the way
that the chemical containment issues we
hopes could be solved but I would feel
pretty uncomfortable about agreeing this
application
now so at a point when the environment
agency and the Water Authority were
satisfied I would feel um that perhaps
then I could with some trepidation go
ahead but certainly not at the moment so
as we always say I will listen to the
rest of the debate but my view at the
moment is that rejection would be
appropriate of course or deferral to the
point which we have a clear and unequal
call answer from the two professional
agencies involved thank you thank you
councelor field and with that in mind um
Mr pman chi I just want to cover this
recommendation because with the points
you've just raised I think it's
important the recommendation is that
Chief PL offs be authorized to Grant
plan permission subject to the agreement
with the environment agency and their
points or should their holding
objections be maintained refuse planning
permission so does that not cover
it my feeling is that moves the
presumption to one of approval and
pressurizes those two agencies
to adjust their uh opinions to fit our
agreement Mr Po
please I'm trying to think of when
environment agency have ever adjusted
their opinions to fit ours um I can't
think of anything um ultimately the
environment AG agency have a
responsibility of their own to to look
after water supplies and uh all the
other roles that they have and of course
the difficulty with planning is
sometimes we step over and and duplicate
other authorities jobs um and I think in
this case what we were trying to do is
to sort of say as officers is there any
other planning issues that get in the
way of this Beyond just that point of
contamination or risk of
and on that score we're still relying on
the environment agency so that is the
position we took but I can understand if
members feel they do not have all of the
information they feel is necessary for
them to make the planning judgment on
the application including the final view
of the environment agency that is a
position you may wish to take forward
and say defer on that basis
perhaps hope that FS debate uh councilor
Manel please uh thank you um I I I
completely agree with with much of what
my fellow councelor field has just said
uh but I I'm I'm a bit concerned about
the fact that we've got um a site here
with all those other buildings that
aren't really considered when it comes
to the consult responses and um I just
think a lot awful lot of cases that it's
come to committee these days we are
really at the whim of what our
professional consules tell us and here
we are with a highways agency comment
saying yeah it's fine and even if we
whether or not we disagree with the fact
that yeah it's fine to have this this
turning off the
a140 they've put that response in terms
of um only some of these buildings being
used and here we are we're saying the
whole s can be
B2 so if it's all put into use then that
amount of traffic that's going up down
that that um driveway on and off the A4
a140 could be 10 times more and we
haven't got any comments about that um
so um and I'm quite sure I think this is
a wonderful industry um and I'm
fascinated by that material um having
got a materials engineering degree um
I'd love to investigate it a bit more so
thank you very much for bringing it in
that was the most that's very
interesting for me um but uh uh and I
think this is an industry fit for the
21st century and I wish you all the best
and I think you'll want to expand into
those other buildings and that will
generate more traffic uh and I that's
what concerns me um I I really think
that I'd love this to go ahead but I'm
just not sure about that um that the the
fact that we got all these deliveries
and they will grow hopefully this will
be a growing industry and um we don't
really have um enough information
about the use of the whole site and how
that is going to impact on highways and
the access thank you thank you councelor
Matson followed by councelor eburn
please thank you yeah I I mean I'm I
think I was somewhat reassured regarding
the actual chemicals and and and having
the environment agency you know standing
behind us to to to um to make sure that
that aspect is all right but C can I
just just say that the area of this site
is is just slightly less than the um the
elmswell housing site that we looked at
first thing this morning that gives you
some idea it's enormous I mean three
three three hectares it's a huge area
and um 6,000 odd square meters of of um
of buildings is a huge amount of
buildings uh and um you know I'm
absolutely agree this is you know
instead of importing these panels from
Sweden and Continental Europe and so on
um to make them here fantastic yes we
want to do this and you know I I would
want to support this if members if if
officers can find a way of of
ensuring um that we limit it to to a
volume um at least until such times as
as as the applicant is able to
um get agreement and buy the land in
order to create um a
satisfactory um Entrance Road and um and
visibility displays and so on and so
forth as um as Council string has um
described um and and then and then yes
great let's expand and let's let's make
lots of more of it because um it's it's
good um so that is that is the big
problem I would like to support it if
officers can find a way
of of doing what I say which is is to
put some sort of constraint
on how much it does I mean we've got 40
employees we've got a certain amount of
hgv movements I I think we we actually
need more than that to to to
constrain within
what's highways think is acceptable um
an acceptable entrance onto the a140
which which is has been said by the
objector and by W member is not um is
not good at
all and before I go to Mr pman G Mr plat
keep putting your hand unfortunately
you've had your time um you're not
permitted uh to go any further sadly and
I know you're biting it a bit but um not
not PRT it's all done thank you uh Mr
pman
G so listening to what members are
saying I'm just modeling this all over
if I'm summing up the issues that seem
to be coming out we have a concern about
the the groundwater not having
sufficient information around that to
give Assurance to
members uh that's something we were
going to do but obviously you know the
the point here is we haven't got that
before you so you may consider it to be
insufficient
information we have a highways issue
which is a matter of the visibility and
it's an existing access so we've got to
bear that in mind as a material
consideration the visibility we're
saying is safe as far as highways are
concerned but it's the route between the
access to the site and the conflict that
one lry going out something coming in or
one vehicle going out something coming
in and the risk that that has to sit and
wait in an inappropriate location that
may risk safety
and that I'm not sure if that's solvable
given the ownership that appears to be
available but there may be something in
relation to the level of use which is
now becoming questionable in terms of
what buildings are in operation which
buildings are not that materially
affects the level of traffic and it is
perhaps suggested that offic need to
find out more information and more
certainty about that for members to be
assured or otherwise consider this to be
insufficient information at this time
therefore you may consider the a d
deferral I hate to say that word again
um on those points might be appropriate
in this instance so that a package of
measures in relation to those issues
could be better
presented yeah yeah thanks for that I I
was I was obviously rather hoping you're
going to C conjure up um even at the
expense of a 10minute recess or
something the the ways and means but but
um you're not councelor Matson that's
exactly what I'm thinking because I'm
conscious of the time I'm conscious of
the fact you've not had lunch yet and it
will close very shortly um we can
continue this uh or we could take a
10-minute break to allow you to go and
consider
that my problem with what we're talking
about is that it's going to need a
discussion with the applicant to
understand what is within their powers
and and operation of the business so
therefore I can't I I think it would be
unreasonable for me to come up with an
awful lot of conditions to try and scope
around the the issues when I think
really needs applicant participation say
I mean CH if I mean there's nothing
wrong Mr with the applicant whispering
in Mr pman G if because he's not a
voting member of the Committees but yes
I mean we I think whether we decide to
take a break that would allow people to
take lunch that could be utilized in
um um yeah it's my proposal that's
that's what we're going to do we'll take
a 10-minute recess um allow you get some
lunch refresh yourselves and please have
that conversation uh with that legal
advice we're required thank
you
ladies and gentlemen uh welcome back to
committee a and uh we're still within DC
um 0148 we're still in debate um before
we go back to debate um
John so during the break uh the case
officer myself and the applicant did
have a discussion about what had been
discussed so far um we have a suggestion
of conditions to resolve perhaps some of
the issues that have been raised um so
in addition to what is in your
papers uh either as additional
conditions or slight modification of the
conditions that are already there we are
suggesting that we add the following
that could possibly reassure members
around the operational side of this
proposal firstly there should be no
outside storage unless agreed um I will
pick that up because I don't think that
was put in previously and I think we
probably should put should have put that
in
there uh the second addition is
restriction on the use of buildings and
land to the manufacturer of insulated
panels
only with incidental storage and office
use
in other words we're not just saying B2
anymore we're getting rid of that
condition we're going to say it's purely
that
manufacturing only that's
it
um obviously that will come with some
administrational function on site and
that comes with storage of stuff as well
but that the main use has to be
that the next point we were going to put
forward to you would be that the use of
the buildings themselves in terms of
their individual operation ations to be
agreed with the local planning Authority
prior to
commencement um it would be in general
Accord with the plan that we've already
seen But we would like the certainty of
knowing exactly what operations go in
each building and that is to be agreed
with the
authority and lastly a scheme of
delivery management of materials to be
agreed that includes or will include
limit to the hours of delivery both to
and from the site number of trips and
the operation of a ring ahead strategy
for hgv to be secured Now by that I
don't know how to phrase it but
essentially if they know they've got a
big Lory coming it has to ring ahead so
they can ensure that it can come
straight
in that is as far as we can go in that
context as far as the uh groundwater
matter is concerned we are still with
the position that we need
information well we are still looking to
approve this subject to environmental
agency having no further objections and
removing their holding objection and any
if they do remove their holding
objection any further conditions they
wish to imply we would imply those as
well however if members are still not
comfortable with that delegation then my
recommendation would still be to defer
it until we have that information from
the environment agency thank you um
first it's councelor eburn from my
memory then councelor
pasmore um thank you very much chair and
thank you um John for those additional
um conditions um you know it's it's good
to see a company being able to expand
and I really welcome the um applicants
explanation of their business I think
that's really helpful to us um I might
just add we have got a great site on
Gateway 14 if you need a big site to
expand to but but we are looking at what
we're looking at um and I do think it's
a shame that some of this hasn't been
sorted out before we got to this point
however I do welcome the um discussions
between the applicant and um the
planning officer on that
front um my um biggest concerns were
with regards to um the the chemicals and
it's not so much their use actually on
the site given the explanation we've had
from the applicant but the fact that if
there was to be an accident or crash or
whatever on the access road or and bid
on the
a140 um it's you know that that would be
a huge issue and you know we are aware
of of um you know and all all of us have
used the a140 the difficulties is there
and it is a shame um I think that the
Highway's response hasn't been um
provided in Greater depth um for this um
application um I would like to see the
um
conditions
um be in to include not just the
environment agency but Essex and suffk
water because I understand from reading
the back papers that ess6 and suffk
Waters um involvement wasn't until a
wasn't right up front as it were and I
think we do need to have yes they might
be um it might be their view that goes
on to the environment agents view but I
think for the sake of residents um and
the community we do need to see the it
stated in the conditions that it's
discussions with environment agency and
Essex and suffk
water um my and my one slight concern is
really is that we the recommendation
talks about um the subject to the
agreement of the agent of of the
environment agency which I think should
be and6 and St at water but to what time
frame I mean are we talking weeks months
you know how long are we talking to S to
to sort this out um because I think
there does need to be some certainty
both for the afan and for the the
community in terms of of what's
happening on this site um so I'll I'll
leave it there at the moment but my
concerns are still the the the you
know risk of a
accident outside of the actual um
industrial process such as on the access
road and also ensuring um you know and
the highway highways kind of comments
and ensuring that we do get the ensure
that Essex and suffk water is fully
involved in in this ultimate decision
thank you very much chair thank you
councilor pmore please my turn um thank
you Barry well uh I've listened to what
has been just agreed with the extra
conditions that um John has just
described and I actually pretty much
content with this so I'm actually going
to propose approval uh there are just a
couple of other points I want to add
though on the basis of the additional
conditions I think just to reassure
people I'm not an expert in the
logistics business but I do know my
previous um farming days and some of the
uh um information I've had from Felix do
do you can schedule deliveries I don't
think we're talking about large numbers
of um articulated lores I absolutely get
the issue living on the a140 myself as I
do uh I do understand about the turning
in and out um of side entrances onto the
road without a a good good visibility
display I get that but I I think with a
well-managed site access plan or
whatever you like to call it that can be
done Felix do do we've got an automated
one and I know going to abattoirs and
other deliveries it's scheduled so
technology can be there to help and I
don't think we're talking about vast
numbers either here so I I would be
happy to go along with that no problem
at all if we want to add consultation
with Essex and suff water um as part of
the environment agency I suspect they
will probably defer to the environment
agency because they are the lead
Authority and one has to take some of
these things on trust that actually the
environment agency will do a proper job
as regards um your comment um Rachel and
concern which I think we all share
should there be any
accidents awful lot of regulations for
transportation of hazardous substances
again there's an element of trust we do
have um on the policing side commercial
vehicle unit which is um does help with
enforcement and I can tell you that if
people do flat the regulations and they
get caught and found guilty well then
they can have their operators license
drawn withdrawn and that effectively
puts them out of business so I think
those are safeguards it's not directly a
planning issue but I do think it's worth
mentioning because of the concern about
transportation of hazardous substances
and um the only question I was just
going to ask John if I may chairman
these conditions I suppose will be
backed up with enforcement not because
I'm in any way questioning the
applicants or the current owners of the
site but we always need to remember if a
site is sold or whatever happens in the
future you can get other people who come
along and therefore the conditions need
to stay with the site it's not down to
the actual individual and I always think
that's something that sometimes we we we
need to perhaps remember that's why I
think it's is important they are
enforceable and I would imagine the
answer to that question maybe
yes
yes thank you so we do have a proposal
um I require a second it
please yeah councelor mayor please yeah
I think on balance I'm prepared to
Second um The Proposal I don't
have any concerns over the environment
agency I don't have the knowledge I
don't have the skills they do hence I
have to trust that they will come to a
sensible um conclusion I do struggle
slightly over the um highways issue
and their statement that there will be a
minimum minimal increase in traffic I
I'm not sure that's
right but they are the authority and
they have given us some advice and given
the additional conditions that we've put
on to control traffic to a limited
extent on balance I am prepared to
support the
proposal thank you councelor Mansel
followed by councelor Matson thank you
chair I I actually just had a question
really of uh of John um about the final
um additional recommendation that he uh
suggested which I think um was about the
scheme of delivery to be agreed or words
to that effect um can I just be
reassured that should presumably with
the company at its current um size will
have some delivery and um access um ARR
Ms but should in the course of time it
expand and they realize they need three
times as many deliveries do they then
need to come back to you again and say
can we do this as our schedule of
deliveries because I don't want to
prevent the growth of the company and um
and I just while i' while I'm here can I
also comment on councelor eber's concern
about the road traffic accidents with
the chemicals on board well that's a
outside of our remix it and will
probably happen anyway U because all
sorts of nasty noxious chemicals are
transported on a daily basis and and yet
they could have an accident so I don't
think we can actually do anything about
that
unfortunately if I may answer that um
well there's two aspects to it actually
access management plan delivery
management plan whatever we want to call
it ultimately it will
set restrictions in terms of the
deliveries number of trips and if uh
those trips go up they would have to
obviously come back and get that re
agreed um because that would be the way
that condition would work uh at the same
time we've gone obviously a step further
here we've actually said that the use of
the buildings we are going to
specifically look at in terms of
operation so of course if there's an
expansion that would also have to be
reassessed or looked at again in the
form of a a further application there so
um there is multiple layers of controls
um and of course we controlling the use
not to say it's a general B2 anymore we
are saying it's specifically that and no
other um so we have got quite strict
here councelor Matson please yeah thank
you um yeah I could I just clarify that
did Mr pman G said said that say that
his preference was for a deferral or he
didn't say that I said the batter of the
groundwater is still an issue now then
you know we your my preference would be
to defer and then come back with that
information at the moment your
recommendation is still to Delegate for
us to look at and of course what's been
added to that is Essex and uh suff water
um
but you know if if you still feel you
don't have sufficient Assurance around
that issue your other option my
recommendation would be to
defer
can I talk about um conditions for a
moment then chair um there there's three
points I'd like to make if we're going
to control the use of individual
buildings then um we we could um
similarly the sound there's no point in
asking for sound insulation on buildings
that going to be storage only um and
secondly on the um illumination um not
adversely affecting in Impact ing
ecology um we've now started to um ask
for those to be agreed prior to
commencement and I think that's
requested or something on page
469 and um thirdly there's also a
request of fire hydrants which hasn't
made it as far as the conditions
yet
Dan are you able to update me on the
fire we could add if it's require is
that we missed that we okay my apologies
for that one uh we will add fire
hydrants and proposer and second are you
happy with that Amendment thank
you anybody else wish to enter debate
yeah councelor field please
I just point out to recognize the
Improvement that you've made that's
worthwhile but uh I'm afraid I still
believe that we should wait until we've
got a a positive feedback from the
environment agency and from the uh water
company uh I don't know I tend to react
a lot to uh the MDI definition of a
substance have to say I just looked up
to boo Des Aster but that was MCI not
MDI so I recognize that perhaps it's
Ancient Memories that are triggering
somewhat more caution but I shall still
be voting against thank
you thank you anybody
else okay for my pennyworth um I support
local businesses I understand the need
for Change and diversity in business and
I think this is a great business
probably to be in so I wish you all
success with with it um and the extra
employment is going to bring to this
District which cannot be overlooked um
the fact is one site and therefore we're
reducing perhaps our system of
sustainability that's also good I think
there's enough mitigation in now to
prevent the fears that we had initially
when we started the debate um I also
believe in the recommendation that the
important part really that you could
refuse it based on those environmental
agency uh measures not being met is
important and I get the additional
conditions which will support that even
further so um it was nice to see debate
discussion compromise communication they
all work don't they in the end and we've
come to a conclusion that we have a
proposal on the table and therefore I'm
going to ask Mr Payton G to please read
out uh the
recommendation so I've written the whole
thing out again because I just thought
in my head it makes a bit more sense to
make sure I've got it all in one place
um so from the
top the recommendation is that the
planning uh sorry that the chief
planning officer be authorized to Grant
planning permission subject to the
agreement of the environment agency and
eics and suff water or should their
holding objection be maintained refuse
planning permission for such reasons
considered oh sorry we a get a f right
so we've got agreement with development
agency and se6 and suff water should
their holding objection be maintained we
refuse it on grounds considered
defendable by officers at
Appeal on the basis that they don't
withhold their objections we then
approve subject to the following
conditions we have Standard time limit
uh development in accordance with the
approved plans sustainability report uh
to detail compliance with core strategy
sc3 um site boundary levels to be no
greater than 5 DBA above background
levels sound installation on all
buildings to be agreed that may may mean
that we don't agree to all the
buildings um restriction on location of
noisy activities on site so they only
occur within insulated buildings sound
installation on external plant machinery
and equipment to be agreed limit to
hours of work applying to the office and
Manufacturing process proposed on site
use of crew buses for late even evenings
and night workers restriction on parking
on site for late evening and night
workers details of any illumination to
be agreed as such that light is
restricted to the site site itself and
external illumination to be set to be in
motion activated during the night hours
and for lighting to not adversely impact
ecology such conditions considered to be
necessary following discussions of the
environment agency and now suff and
essic water plus the following condition
that we have as
officers yep we're getting there plus
the additional conditions that we've
suggested which are no outside storage
unless agreed insulation on the use of
the sorry restriction on the use of the
buildings and land to manufacturing of
insulation panels only with incidental
storage and office use the use of the
buildings in terms of individual
operations to be agreed but in general
accordance with the plan provided scheme
of delivery management for materials to
be agreed that the includes limits to
hours delivery both to and through the
site number of trips and operations of a
ring ahead strategy for hgv to be
secured and far hydrants have I missed
anything so proposal and second are you
happy with what's been read before you
and uh members all happy with the
proposal thank you therefore I'll ask
the uh governance offic to conduct the
electronic vote CLA thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress
thank you members chair that's six votes
for and one against that's
carried thank you we're now going to
move on to
uh we're going to move on to agenda item
7f which is uh the erection of two
modular units to provide homeless
accommodation at six Road Stow
Market before we do that we'll just let
people swap seats and then we'll come
back to the
point um Mr P can I confirm you're
actually presenting this thank
you
yeah
ladies and gentlemen um I'll now ask uh
John P G to introduce the application to
the committee thank
you so again uh unfortunately the
officer in question was ill today um so
I am hopefully seeking to present this
and uh
apologies for the presentation in that
context right so this is a proposal this
is a full application um I like these uh
for the erection of two modular units to
provide homeless accommod
and uh essentially I'm just going to run
through the slid so the location is uh
66 which Road in Stone
Market um just to come out you'll notice
we're on the southern side of uh one one
stone Market uh the Town Center is just
out of sight up the top
here and if I scroll
down that's the location
site
we are in the conservation area as
you'll walk up to the town
center and the site is uh existing
property on the
front and the proposal is to put the two
units in the rear uh Amin
area and alongside just to North here
we've got a a private road that leads up
and of course we''ve got the parking
being an Associated garage just in here
off an existing
AIS the proposed unit themselves this is
a uh aent uh unit uh it's not a a
caravan it is a a construction with a
foundation uh to consist of the two
units and these are photos of the site
so that's the property at the
front uh that's the track uh the well
the Private Road Track to the uh to the
north of the site uh just
there and the main road and this is the
property and it's at the back of the
property that we're talking
about and there we are at the
back I just run through the photographs
so essentially the units would be
sighted within that
area fairly enclosed and out of sight of
the public realm for the most
part uh the road to the north of the
site does go up a small hill so you
possibly would be able to look over and
down onto the buildings a little
bit as demonstrated by that
picture the conclusion being that the
application proposal would have no
detrimental impact on the character or
appearance of the surrounding area in
office of opinion The Proposal would not
impact the site access or parking
facilities
and the proposal would not have a
significant impact on the Privacy
amenity of nearby neighboring dwellings
The Proposal would not in our opinion
represent any demonstration or harm of
planning substance and therefore your
recommendation before you is one of
approval uh subject to conditions of the
standard time limit approved plans uh a
limit on construction working hours to
safeguard amenity in the area and also
an occupation restriction so this
is secured as a home
uh accommodation unit and that's all
thank you thank you members do you have
any questions yes uh councilor maton
followed by councilor Manel yeah the the
uh I need
to declare that I have visited the site
three or four years ago but I have been
there um yes the wanted to identify
what's the private um amenity space
that's available to the um
I think typically two families uh in the
house as well as the um prospective
occupants of the two
units if it will help it might might be
better when we speak to um the agent
indeed it may help but I if we can just
put uh I hate to say could you put the
PowerPoint back on again
please just demonstrate on the proposed
plan oh sorry got on there
but if I just quickly whiz back to the
layout plan uh apologies that could have
done would have been zoomed in a bit
more but um
essentially this is going to be serving
as the amenity space for parking and
returning maneuvering um which would
leave essentially this Courtyard space
in in the middle uh to be outside space
uh to to be shared as as an outside
amenity space if I have that wrong or
any other points I I'm sure
they this is
just that's part of the just general
outdoor space that surrounds the
building yeah I mean my concern is that
there's adequate outdoor space for two
families and two
couples
question ultimate
pH ultimately you know it's a shared
space and it is relatively uh
small um if that helps yeah but of
course the unit would use up some of
that land in this space only really
providing you with that sort of area
there and a bit of the
side there are obviously Parks quite
close by and would been walking distance
because of the middle being in the
middle of Stow
Market yeah so can officers help us with
what that other piece of we can't
actually we not got photograph of that
even coming round to that do you you
mean this this section is just the side
yes that one just property
yeah I'd imagine the main amenity space
to serve the units would be this
immediate space just a sort of small
courtyard in the middle of the site yeah
okay thank you thank you councelor Mel
please uh thank you um firstly I've got
I've got a number of of things I want to
ask actually um on on page 485 of the um
the electronic version probably page
number um there's a tree that's going to
be removed which which is not considered
to be particular significance but it
does look quite nice and it does make a
nice sort of green green area so
although it's not uh we're not saying we
need to protect it but any chance of
replanting another Tree in instead
that's my first um query um and can I
just go to the description of the
development we have a full planning
application for the erection of two
modular units to provide homeless
accommodation so um one if they are
approved um they will always be for
homeless accommodation or is that
nothing to do with planning um uh and my
third query um I've just heard from my
neighbor talking about two families
living in the house I presume but yet
it's says it's been converted to five
single person flatlets so I'm a bit
confused about where the two families
have have
gone um
I sorry the in terms of the these units
these would be uh subject to an
occupation condition to that effect so
unless that condition is sought
separately for a separate planning
application to be removed they would be
maintained thereafter for just that
purpose um I don't know the situation
with regard to the existing building I'm
afraid to say but yeah
um and the tree where would you like to
put a tree sorry I just thought if we're
losing a tree um you know to to set the
balance right we need to plant another
one somewhere else on the plot that's
all I'm saying can I leave that for your
debate of whether that wishes to be
something you
impose councilor field
please thank you I noticed the suff fire
and rescue service is recommending
automatic far sprinkler systems as they
often do
for dwellings of this type um I wonder
have we rejected that or is that part of
the
plans it's 493 on mine but
um
essentially that is then standard
advisory
letter um that I've got here it's not
something it says yes so essentially it
provides that consideration be given to
they I hate to say that they tend to do
this for everything um we we don't
generally uh go down that road um as as
a policy position
but we are in a town there are easy
access to fire hydrant within that
locality we could be question ably
saying it's unreasonable to impose
something like that but I I get where
you're coming from from safety but it's
not something we regularly
do I take your point but obviously
people who've been homeless may be uh
more inclined to accidents of that
nature unfortunately I would say that's
a judgment on people rather than a
planning
matter any other
questions okay thank you so we've got no
uh public speakers no one from the
parish council although I do have some
statements which we I'll read out of the
W members shortly um no objectiv no
support but we do have the agent which
is Lucy Smith um Lucy you have three
minutes from the time you begin to start
to talk thank
you hi good afternoon my name is Lucy
Smith I'm a planner in gutam wood on
behalf of the applicant I'd like to
thank members members and officers for
the opportunity to speak today as
presented the proposed development
comprises a single building with two
separate one-bedroom units to be used as
temporary move on units for identified
homeless people these will be used
whilst being assisted to find longer
term
accommodation this will essentially be
an extension to the existing use of Eric
Jones house which is also used as
supported accommodation for
homelessness The Proposal is a modular
unit from company which specializes in
this type of building they're designed
to be cost effective accessible and
sustainable they're steel frame Timber
paneled buildings the unit contains the
kitchen living area bedroom and bathroom
although they have the potential to
accommodate up to four people it was
more likely that they will be occupied
with one person per
unit the proposed units are cited to the
existing rear Garden of Eric James house
the proposal has been signed to be
subordinate and small scale as possible
while whilst providing the required
accommodation there is amenity space
remaining on site including the grass
area to the side of the existing
property and to the South is the the
existing garage and large parking area
access from IP Switch
Road in design terms the proposed
building is very simple and functional
low level with a flat roof predominantly
cladded but with a brick plin um it's
not considered in congress with a street
scene or Conservation Area to the height
and orientation of The Proposal in
relation to the neighboring property
that's not considered to be an adverse
impact on amenity through loss of light
being overbearing or loss of
privacy um just to reiterate there is an
identified need in the district for
emergency housing for homeless
people um policies of the core strategy
and National planning policy framework
encourage provision of a mix of housing
type to cater for different
accommodation needs of the district
including suit provision of purpose
built accommodation given the benefits
of the scheme and contribution
contributing to mids suffix housing
facilities it's considered that the
principle of development is
acceptable there are no objections from
statutory consules nor the Town Council
and therefore no planning reasons as to
why permission should not be granted we
therefore respectively request that
members endorse a recommendation of the
officer and Grant delegated authority to
approve um the application subject to
the conditions thank you thank you good
timing um are there any questions please
yes Council Manel followed by Council
Eben uh thank you could you please um
let us know what the existing use of
Eric Jones house is is it five single
homeless accommodation or or you know
are they are we effectively extending
that five into seven or are they
completely different uses thank you I'll
come on that point I'm Hazel Ard
assistant manager for strategic property
so far as oversee the Council housing
delivery on behalf of two councils so
Eric Jones House itself at the moment is
used as temporary accommodations so they
self-contained units the idea of these
two um units is to provide move on
accommodation so it's about enabling
people to move on temporary
accommodation a kind of transition into
Independence and sustaining their own
tency so they will be provided with
support and a support plan from support
well from from a support provider but
also using other agencies exist already
um without of ours when required at
weekends and in the evening so it's like
a kind of transition so they move from
one to the other into their own
Tendencies with support I just want to
clarify that the existing house is five
of this type of accommodation already
and we're just putting another two on so
it's like with like
yes chairman um good afternoon Hazel um
we so excuse me Eric Jones house is is
not a hostile doesn't have a resident
manager on site although some degree of
support is offered is it's essentially
accommodation that is for for people in
homelessness situation as I understand
it yet there's not fulltime support on
site but there is obviously support
available thank you councelor e
please thank thank you very much chair
um thanks Hazel and Lucy um so
just my question was part of
councilor manel's already asked but does
that mean then that there is there will
be up to nine people on this site
because these each of these two units
can take two people so that's we're
talking about four potential people plus
five in the existing house so that is up
to nine on this one site just to confirm
yes councilor maton please uh yes so so
you're you're just confirming that the
the the the the use of the the house has
changed from when I was there three or
four years ago to now single homeless
people yes as I as I understand it
yeah yeah well I mean you confident I
mean you you you heard my question to Mr
P G earlier you know it is particularly
about the reasonable amount of outside
space if there were children living
there but but you're saying there were
not children living there so I can
remove my concern
y so there are single people and couples
and then these two units would be for
single people and couples okay thank you
are there any other
questions thank you thank you for your
time um we'll now move on to the ward
members sadly councelor Brewster and
councelor scarf can't attend the meeting
but they have asked that their
statements be read so I'll do that
[Applause]
now so the first
um letter is from uh councilor Gerald br
there although there have been a
relatively small number of objections
from the local area overall this
application fits policy and the
consultation with the various strategic
bodies has not brought any major
objections I do agree with the need for
working times to be limited and
personally if it is possible to restrict
contact uh contractor vehicles and
deliveries entering Woodfield Drive
which is a private Drive serving a
number of homes that said Eric John's
house is intended to house those on a
temporary basis and this application
will support rough sleepers and homeless
people again on a temporary basis the
flat roof structures will have a minimum
effect on iwi street as Eric Jones house
is basically in front of the development
of the two structures I have no
objection to this application and trust
that members will look favorably upon
the application and a letter from uh
councilor Keith scarth with regards to
the above application sorry I support
the application in general although
there is the sign significant reduction
in the available former Garden if this
development were to go ahead this I
believe is mitigated by the close
proximity of Pike's Meadow so residents
could utilize this for leisure purposes
there is a proven need for homeless
accommodation and I believe this
application helps us as a council to
provide this need therefore on balance I
support granting of the
permission I'll now open uh this up for
debate who'd like to
start
councelor Manel followed by councelor
pasmo uh thank you chair um I uh I'm
broadly in support of this application
um they're not the most um photogenic
sort of pictures in the in the plans but
um they are going to be behind the
existing house which is a nicely
proportioned um dwelling on on iwit road
um and
um I I I'm well aware of the issue
issues of this sort of type of
accommodation um because there are um a
number five units in elmswell um and
there have been quite a lot of comments
about saying maybe it's more suited that
these people are housed in a place like
Stow Market where they have uh access to
more facilities so I think this is a
suitable location um for this type of
accommodation I'm I'm I'm heartened by
the fact that we're not we're not
putting these type of people um next to
two families which I was a bit concerned
of when councelor mats started talking
about families knowing that some of the
issues that have risen at this type of
accommodation in elmswell um I would
like to see a tree planted somewhere um
in lie of the one that we're losing even
though it's nothing special it does make
a nice sort of greenery area um but um
on the whole I think um I'm prepared to
support this um so um I'll uh I'll um
make a proposal that we go along with
the office recommendation but I would
like to see a tree planted uh somewhere
in the garden thank you and before we go
to find in a second it's like make a
really good point and a valid point um
people have a perception of homeless
people what they are what they might be
accident prone whatever and I've heard
it twice today need to be very careful
because the government policy paper that
was written only last month talks about
homelessness and the need for homeless
accommodation for people who've suffered
domestic abuse require housing because
they've been put out housing due to that
domestic abuse if we go down to the um
homelessness Act of 2002 it talks about
housing
authorities having in place um a
homeless strategy which we have and part
of this requires planning
for securing sufficient accommodation
people who become homeless or are at
risk of becoming homeless so don't
imagine it's people living in just
people living in carb boxes on streets
it's a whole ra of people so please just
bear that in mind I am aware of that I
just know there are been some current
incidents in my ward that's all that
might be the case but let's just keep it
on a level um I'd like a second
please uh not seconding um just a quick
question uh tree are we saying that's
additional condition to say there shall
be a tree planted is is it something
that's conditionable well that's why I'm
asking I I you I can condition I can I
just didn't know if that was an
informative note or I'd like to see a
condition that the tree is replaced by
planting a new tree somewhere in the
garden okay so I I can do that as a you
know prior to occupation a tree shall be
planted to replace the one that removed
in a suitable location and leave that
with the applicant to devise the
suitable location that's sufficient
thank you thank you uh do we have a
second please uh councelor field was
first yes I'm happy to Second it I think
I was a bit concerned when I read this
application that the analysis of our
policies was different to that analysis
of the sign policies in a previous
document but I accept it makes no I'm
sure it makes no difference to the uh
suitability of this I was also a little
concerned about the lack of amenity
space uh people might be faced with but
not not a big
issue H we're assured that it's
acceptable and taking the point that
it's not families it's single people
that makes a difference I think um also
the automatic fire alarm systems you
know
one accepting the thought that one hopes
one's not being prejudiced about
particular people and and their their
Origins but it but it always is a risk R
and I know the far Brigade um somewhat
before GFI to were very keen on um
on that as a solution to to far problems
in various places but nevertheless with
all those things it's clearly good to be
providing accommodation for for people
who are unfortunate enough to finish up
homeless as you said for whatever of a
wide range
of condition reasons so I'm very happy
to support to a second list
thank you anybody else wish to continue
the debate councilor mayor
please thanks chair
um I'm slightly concerned the SES going
to be overdeveloped there's very little
space outside um the new unit is
considerably bigger than the existing
house suppose that has to be balanced
against the um public benefit for doing
what we're doing also have a problem
with the tree it's it we're planting
tree very close to the foundations of
either the house or the the Brick plinth
with the underground pipe work etc so I
think careful selection of tree species
or potentially hedro would be a better
option and I'm not sure that's um for us
to
actually decide so on balance I think it
is um in the public benefit but I think
it is almost overdevelopment of the site
thank you anybody
else okay um before we finish then um
for my own penworth this is really is
required we're in that world aren't we
where we need to afford that
accommodation to people who are
unfortunate to be in that situation just
tick that box massively I get the um the
over de development statement wholly but
I'd rather have these people have a roof
over their head than worry about how
much Garden space they've got In
fairness um it right as well that we
spent time debating this and and put due
diligence into it bearing in mind that
we're the applicant as mids District
Council so it's right and proper to do
it the way we've done it um we do have a
proposal do have a second I'd like the
area manage uh area planning manager to
read out the proposal on the table
please so your proposal is as recommend
recommended u in your papers with the
additional condition of a replacement
tree to be planted in a suitable
location on site
um and that's it proposer and second are
both
happy thank you uh therefore I'll ask
the governance officer to go for the
electronic vote thank you CLA thank
you members that
vote it's now in progress in your
app
thank you members chair that's seven
votes for that's
unanimous thank you
carried site inspections are there any
site inspections no no thank you
um it'd be uh wrong to end the meeting
without saying thank you to Robert
Carmichael I know that the chair Matthew
Hicks already said a few things uh I'd
like to thank you personally for all
that you did for me when I was the
chairman of the council um the work that
you do in the background is absolutely
critical to the success of this Council
uh and you've been a backbone of it so
thank you personally on behalf of this
committee and for committee b as well
and I'm sure of all the counselors that
serve on this Council and its supporting
offices for everything you've done um
it's our sad loss to see you go but I'm
sure you're Overjoyed with your new job
and and the potential and the sort of
possibilities that's going to bring for
you I'm sure you'll be immensely
successful wherever you go so thank you
for everything you've done uh
Robert uh with that I now formally close
the meeting thank you for your
attendance and be
safe